Ja, Hendrik, ich würde mal sagen, heute reden wir mal nicht über Programmiersprachen.
Achso. Okay. Ja, dann...
Ja.
Der nächste Podcast in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in 3, 2...
Ja, hi Kilian.
Hey Hendrik.
Wie geht's?
Super.
Bei dir?
Sehr gut.
Ich habe gerade entdeckt, dass ich hier nur 50 Meter von einem Eisladen direkt auf der
Straße weg wohne und wir haben das gerade zum ersten Mal ausprobiert.
Das war eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, voll lecker.
Kann man jetzt im Sommer häufiger mal machen, finde ich.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich da jetzt jeden Tag auf dem Heimweg nochmal dran.
Bei so paar 30 Grad draußen kannst du auch in die Sauna zum Abkühlen gehen.
Das ist nicht so ein Postillonartikel von vorgestern.
wegen Paar sitzt in Sauna und findet erst einen Tag fünf raus,
dass das Ding endlich funktioniert.
Passt.
Ja, das wundert mich überhaupt nicht.
Also gestern hat es ja hier gewittert und ich habe irgendwie,
das wird ja vorher nochmal richtig schön kühl,
ich bin irgendwie eine Viertelstunde lang durch meine Wohnung gelaufen
und habe dafür gesorgt, dass alle Fenster weit offen bleiben
und habe immer geguckt, dass es gerade noch nicht reinregnet
und habe den Moment, bis ich die Fenster zumachen konnte,
so weit wie möglich hinausgezögert.
Mir haben ein bisschen Luftaustausch stattfinden lassen.
Ich habe ja leider diese Dachwohnung, die dann doch
einen Tick warm wird.
Aber na gut.
Kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Wir waren auch im dritten Stock.
Das ist sehr unangenehm bei den Temperaturen.
Wenn nicht noch irgendwie 10 Stockwerke drüber sind.
Nur eine oder gar keine.
Genau.
Aber deswegen kann man ja auch rausgehen
und sich irgendwie Podcast
aufsetzen und sich
mit den Füßen
ins Wasser setzen
und
sich ein Eis holen. Also ich hoffe, ihr hört die Folge
gerade irgendwo, wo es kühl ist.
Gut gekühlt.
Zum Beispiel in der Sauna.
Ja, was haben wir denn heute für Themen?
Vieles. Wir haben tatsächlich ein bisschen was
zusammengesammelt bekommen.
Pollen wir doch mal an. Top Nummer 1.
Good News. Wir haben heute mal sortiert
nach Good News, Bad News, obwohl
ein paar von den Sachen sind ja nicht ganz
kann ich jetzt nicht ganz so gut entscheiden.
Also ich habe von GitHub
diesen Vorschlag bekommen. Möchtest du nicht
die Beta von unserem neuen Dashboard ausprobieren?
Hast du das gemacht? Ja, habe ich auch gemacht. Ich finde es auch
besser als vorher. Findest du es besser? Ich finde,
das ist irgendwie, also ich fand es ja schon schwierig,
dass sie diese Repositories-Liste
von rechts nach links geschoben haben.
Ja, das ist hier immer noch kacke, weil das macht das gerade.
Jetzt hat die Seite, finde ich,
noch mehr irgendwie was, also vorher
war das dieses Bootstrap-ige
Container-Design, wo alles
in der Mitte war und links und rechts war Luft.
Das fand ich eigentlich sehr angenehm. Jetzt ist links
voll, rechts ist voll und
in der Mitte ist ein Feed. Ich finde, jetzt sieht es aus wie
ein weißes Facebook. Du hast recht,
es zieht sich auf die ganze Breite. Ich habe meinen Browser immer auf
so einer Breite, so zwei Drittel
MacBook 15 Zoll gehöse. Also ich habe jetzt hier links so eine
Liste, zwei Listen mit einem Filter,
Your Repositories und Your Teams.
Auf der rechten Seite steht Discover
Repositories. Ja, aber bei BD
fällt mir jetzt gerade erst auf, dass das Ding hier auf die ganze Breite
sich hinspreizt und nicht
Platz lässt. Genau.
Und in der Mitte ist irgendwie jetzt hier ein Newsfeed.
Also ich muss sagen, ja.
Ich finde es wieder angenehmer, als es
vorher war, mit dem einfach nur
die Repos auf die linke Seite umziehen.
Vielleicht muss ich es einfach wieder zusammenquetschen.
Dann ist nämlich auch diese rechte
Discover-Repository-Seite weg.
Also gut, also
GitHub entwickelt sich immer weiter.
Ja, GitHub meinst du.
It's called GitHub now.
GitHub?
GitHub mit J.
Wer sagt das?
Das ist ein Tweet von Microsoft direkt nach der Acquisition.
It's called GitHub now.
Ich schaue gerade mal auf
GitHub.com.
die Seite ist...
Da läuft tatsächlich so ein
Microsoft-Webserver drauf.
Ist das so ein Standard-Flash-Page von irgendeinem Ding?
Oder IIS
ist doch das Ding. Das leitet weiter auf
go.microsoft.com
GitHub.com
Gut, okay.
Random Erkenntnis
des Tages.
Nee, das Dashboard hat sich geändert.
Ja, gibt wahrscheinlich verschiedene Meinungen zu.
Ich finde es okay.
Dieses Discover-Repository,
da schaue ich manchmal rein, aber das ist häufig
so absolutes
Mainstream-Zeugs.
Bei Discovern tue ich doch schon Dinge, die in der Mitte kommen.
Da muss ich doch nicht mehr...
In der Mitte musst du halt den richtigen Leuten folgen.
Wenn du GitHub so benutzt
wie Twitter, dann ist auch was Interessantes.
Das mache ich.
Bei mir haben sich ja schon Leute beschwert, ich soll nicht so viel Zeug starten.
Das wurde mir auch mal gesagt.
Da habe ich gesagt, du musst einfach mehr Leuten folgen.
Du musst einfach GitHub wie ein Social Network benutzen.
So schäme ich aber auch manchmal,
wenn ich bei random Leuten
in einem Vortrag oder sonst was
die machen GitHub auf und dann
die Frontpage gefüllt von Kieran sagt,
das, das, das, das, das, das, ja,
Entschuldigung.
Du bist so eine GitHub-Ure, ey. Ja, du auch.
Ja, wir sind zwei GitHub-Uren.
Das ist ein folgtetitel.
Was ich auch schon bei Leuten
gesehen habe, zum Beispiel hier mein Kumpel
Jan Lillis, der auch
sehr viele Ruby-Gems veröffentlicht,
wenn der ein neues Projekt anfängt und das irgendwie geil findet
und sagt, das will ich jetzt publishen,
dann startet er das erstmal selber.
sein eigenes Ding.
Jan Lellis start
Jan Lellis slash so und so.
Ich meine, warum startet er das selbst?
So kannst du natürlich da hinpassen. Das stimmt.
Das habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht. Ich habe immer entweder
Dinge, die ich öffentlich machen möchte,
aber die ich nicht so öffentlich
machen möchte, werden gleich,
wenn es das leere Repo ist, noch
auf Public gemacht. Dann schauen es Leute an,
aber danach nicht mehr. Oder
du machst es Private, bis es zu einem
vorzeigbaren Punkt ist und machst es Public in dem Moment,
wo du es publishen möchtest.
Ich glaube, private kann ich gar nicht Sachen machen.
Achso, Studentenaccount bei mir wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe einen Studentenaccount nicht mehr.
Das kann ich.
Jaja.
Also GitHub hat sich verändert.
GitHub, ja.
Kompilat.
So, ich habe mich revanchiert.
Genau.
Es gibt wieder neue Programmiersprachen.
Oh, was?
Zwei Sachen, die ich irgendwo
gelesen habe.
ich hatte ja schon mal über Reason
geredet, was so ein OCaml ist, was
von Facebook entwickelt wurde,
quasi OCaml mit einer hübscheren
Syntax,
was nach JavaScript kompiliert.
Und wenn der dann allerdings wirklich
nach JavaScript und nach
Native, angeblich ist der Facebook
Messenger in Reason geschrieben,
allerdings wenn du es nach JavaScript
kompilierst und dann Sachen aus JavaScript benutzen
möchtest, musst du immer
JS. irgendwie davor schreiben und die Sachen
aus der nativen
Standard-Lib
zu verwenden, was ein bisschen
cumbersome ist. Jetzt gibt's
Grainlang, das braucht
auch OCaml zum Bauen und
ist sehr OCaml-esk. Die Dokumentation
ist allerdings noch sehr dürftig.
Und das baut
aber wohl direkt
nach WebAssembly.
Und baut sich dann,
also ich schätze mal, davon werden wir mehr sehen.
Es gibt ja schon
Bösezungen, die behaupten, WebAssembly ist so das
neue Java
Applet-System.
Ja, mehr hoffentlich,
solange das ist mein Wegen.
WebAssembly ist halt
bedeutend geiler.
Ich erwarte, dass wir wesentlich mehr coole
Programmiersprachen sehen, die nach
WebAssembly kompilieren und dann
direkt mit JavaScript-Interface, das wäre schon
ziemlich schön.
All of the types, none of the burdens.
Ich war gerade hier auf der Grain-Seite, sorry.
Genau.
Ja, was ich gerade sagen wollte, also
Rust macht da ja auch schon sehr viel, allerdings
eine Sprache, wo du weniger
dich um die unterschiedlichen
Stringtypen und Speicher kümmern musst,
wäre vielleicht so als Mittelweg
zwischen dieser wirklich, ich kümmere
mich komplett um jede Art von
Datenstrukturtyp.
Swift vielleicht?
Vielleicht eine etwas
weniger umständliche
Sprache.
Und das zweite, was
heute erst,
ich habe es mir nicht intensiv angeguckt,
ist kittenlang.org.
Also ich muss sagen, es gibt allgemein
zwei Kategorien
von Programmiersprachen.
Das sind die,
die in ihrer Website-Domain
vor dem lang ein Dash haben
und die, die keinen Dash haben.
Weil die Webseite von Grain ist
grain-lang.org und die von kitten
ist kittenlang.org.
Kitten ist a
concatenative language.
Gibt es eigentlich.lang schon als TLD?
Es gibt ja dieses
.lang, wer mag wohl?
.nic, falls es das gibt.
.lang?
Ja, genau, so meine ich.
Gibt es nichts. Vielleicht ng?
Es gibt, was viele Projekte machen,
ist ja auf js.org
sich eine Subdomain
einrichten.
Also hier, Webpack
ist auf webhack.js.org
und ein paar andere Projekte
sind auch auf.js.org.
Was eigentlich ganz cool ist.
.js wäre auch eine coole T.
Oh, da würde so viel kaputt gehen drin.
Ja.
Oh ja.
Wie viel Geld braucht man, um sich eine eigene T.
Kann ich.html?
Ich glaube, solche Sachen sind explizit
ausgeschlossen von der Jahre.
Das ist ja langweilig.
Anfänger.
Ja, also Kitten habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Ich habe jetzt auch nicht genau gesehen, was eine konkrete
Native Language ist. Also schaut es euch mal an
und erklärt es mir dann bei Gelegenheit mal bitte.
Aber der in Hello World ist ein
Hello, ein Meow.
Ein Meow say.
Because kittens don't speak English.
Vielleicht ist es auch eine Sch.
Ist das eine E-Solang? Ich weiß es nicht.
Nee, das ist nicht. Sieht ernst gemeint aus.
Aber es sieht so ein bisschen
Syntax-Lang hat mich direkt so an Haskell, wenn ich hier lese.
Ach, kann das sein, dass das rückwärts zu lesen ist
und mal was die machen?
ist man quasi ein Parameter
in den Funktionsaufruf
reinpipet.
Ich sehe eigentlich nur gerade diese
Pfeile und großgeschriebenes I.O.
und ich bin bei Haskell gelandet.
Nö,
muss man sich mal anschauen.
Ja, Kittenlang.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit Ponylang.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Genau.
Was gibt es sonst noch so Neues?
TypeScript 3.0
ist jetzt offiziell released,
Aber wie ich vorhin von dir erfahren habe,
haben wir darüber ja schon gesprochen in der letzten Folge.
Ich habe es einfach komplett vergessen.
Ja, genau. Also letztes Mal habe ich so einen kleinen
Abriss geliefert darüber, was jetzt in TypeScript,
du spielst hier rum, das mal,
was jetzt in TypeScript 3 alles neu ist.
Aber ich könnte ja vielleicht trotzdem nochmal,
ich rede ja schon hier bloß über Rust,
eigentlich benutze ich den ganzen Tag TypeScript
und das Type-System ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Da könnte ich vielleicht mal drei Worte drüber verlieren.
einfach die Inference Engine von
TypeScript ist ziemlich cool. Was sie ja machen, ist, dass sie
eine Sprache, eine
streng typisierte Sprache machen
mit einem ziemlich
coolen Type-System, was zum Beispiel so
Union-Types oder Some-Types zulässt.
Und da kannst du, das geht
bei so Kleinigkeiten los, wenn du zum Beispiel
das geht bei so
Kleinigkeiten wie Literal-Types los. Du kannst
einen Typen haben, der ein String ist.
Und dann kannst du hinschreiben,
mein
Name ist vom Typ
Hendrik und dann kann dieser
variablen Name keinen anderen String
annehmen als Hendrik.
Da bin ich total fasziniert, dass ich das erste Mal TypeScript
angeschaut habe, dass man sowas machen kann,
beziehungsweise dass sie das so machen und dass man
darüber ja I-Names und Strings auch super abbilden kann.
Beziehungsweise so ähnlich.
Aber das geht ja auch bei den
TypeScript. Du kannst es zumindest benutzen, um
Tags für Tag Unions zu schreiben.
Das heißt, du hast zwei Interfaces,
die strukturell identisch sind
und dann kannst du
was haben, was zwei Zustände haben kann,
das eine oder das andere.
Du möchtest dem aber einen Namen geben können
und vom Interface
sind diese beiden Typen aber identisch.
Da wäre, der sagt TypeScript jetzt,
naja, sag ich jetzt nicht Nein zu,
der macht strukturelles Typing.
Wenn du mir was gibst, was genauso aussieht,
obwohl ein anderer Interface-Name dran steht,
nehme ich das auch.
Ja, so auf Interface-Ebene.
Und was du dann machst, ist, dass du noch
einen Tag oder einen Name in das Interface
mit reinschreibst und dann ist dieses Interface
nur gültig, wenn dieser eine
Wert da drin
einen bestimmten, also dieses eine Property da drin
einen bestimmten Wert hat und dann musst du da quasi
einen Tag reinschreiben.
Und auf die Art und Weise kannst du dann
im Typ-System trotzdem
schon zur Compile-Time unterscheiden, was es ist.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Was du auch machen kannst ist,
wenn du irgendwie einen State
beschreibst, dann hast du halt, dann steht da drin
ein String
done in progress
failed zum Beispiel.
Und dann kann dein
State Property den Typen
als Union Type
diese drei Strings haben. Es sind wieder dieser String
oder dieser String oder dieser String.
Und was nice ist, wenn du ein if schreibst
und darauf prüfst
und hinschreibst if
state ist gleich done
oder oder state ist gleich
done, dann schreibt er dir einen Fehler.
Weil sobald
du vorne gecheckt hast
Ob der done ist, steht dir diese Option
hinten nicht mehr zur Verfügung.
Auf die Art und Weise kannst du auch
Typeguards bauen. Das heißt,
ich kriege was rein,
ein Interface, wo
ein Property optional ist, so mit Fragezeichen.
Und dann, wenn du
auf das Property zugreifst, sagst du
.optionalproperty.
Dann sagt er dir,
geht nicht.
Das Ding könnte ja undefined
sein. Und wenn du dann davor
schreibst,
mein Input
Objekt Punkt
Optional, ach das macht sich
ausgesprochen.
Wenn du vorher das Ding mit und und prüfst,
also schreibst Objekt Punkt Property
und und Objekt Punkt Property,
dann hast du ja vorher quasi klargestellt,
okay, der hintere Teil geht nur, wenn das
vorne nicht undefined ist.
Dementsprechend sagt dir dann hinten, okay, jetzt
darfst du drauf zugreifen. Das ist ganz cool.
Und
TypeScript 3, da hat sich
jetzt irgendwie nichts
wirklich Breaking geändert.
Das ist hauptsächlich TypeScript 3.0,
weil die vorherige Version 2.9 hieß.
Und 2.10 war nicht drin.
Und 2.10 wollten sie irgendwie, glaube ich, nicht machen.
Es gibt auch
Systeme, wo sie die Version auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise
geändert haben, damit nichts kaputt geht.
Bei Linux haben sie das zum Beispiel so gemacht.
Windows, Microsoft. Genau.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich hiermit irgendwie sowas geleistet haben,
aber ich glaube es eigentlich nicht.
Und wir hatten ja schon beim letzten Mal
kurz erwähnt, dass das richtig Coole, was dabei
kommen, ist es der unknown type.
Stimmt, das haben wir schon angesprochen.
Siehe, akronomisierbar, Folge 20,
wo ich erzählt habe,
bei TypeScript
bildet JavaScript ab, bei JavaScript kann eine Variable
prinzipiell immer jeden Wert annehmen
und das hat bei TypeScript den Typ any.
Alles ist erstmal prinzipiell any.
Du kannst bei TypeScript strict
any checks oder strict
type checks anmachen und wenn du dann
ein Parameter annimmst und kein Typ dran schreibst, dann
meckert du dich an, dass das ja implizit any
sein könnte und du bitte konkret sein sollst. Dann musst du
explizit any zum Beispiel dran schreiben.
Damit du dem Compiler sagst, ich
meine das ernst.
Wenn du jetzt allerdings
was von außen reinbekommst, wo du typtechnisch
keine Kontrolle drüber hast, weil es zum Beispiel
Input von irgendeinem JSON-Objekt
von einem Server ist oder von irgendwo anders,
dann kannst du zwar sagen,
meine Methode nimmt hier
von diesem Typ das an,
aber da hast du halt
zur Runtime keine Garantien zu.
Du kannst auch nicht TypeScript sagen,
hier, validier mal diesen Input.
Das macht TypeScript nicht. Die haben in ihrer Philosophie
drin, wir generieren
keinen Laufzeitcode.
Die
generieren keinen Code, der die
der die
Validität von Typen checkt.
Was sie jetzt
bei TypeScript 3 eingebaut haben,
ist der Unknown Type.
Da nimmst du quasi jetzt was an, wo du
weißt, ich weiß nicht was das ist, weil ich es von außen
reinkriege. Und um darauf was machen
zu können, im Gegensatz zu Any, wo du immer alles
drauf machen kannst, bei Any habe ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt,
machst du quasi die Typechecks komplett aus.
Bei unknown musst du dem Compiler
beweisen, was das ist, indem du
vorher Typeguards drauf ausrubst. Wie ich es zum Beispiel
gerade geschrieben habe, ich kann
was reinkriegen oder kann ich nicht in Property
X drauf aufrufen, wenn ich nicht vorher
Input.X und
und davor schreibe oder If Input.X
um dem zu sagen, dass es
wirklich da ist. Oder ich kann damit nichts
machen, was eine Methode auf einem String ist, ohne dem
per Typeguard vorher zu beweisen, dass es ein
String ist.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
eine Sache, die übrigens bei 2.8
jetzt mal als kleine Sidenote schon reingekommen ist
sind Dependent-Types
das ist auch eine ziemlich coole Sache
aber das lest ihr euch mal lieber
im Text durch
Handbook TypeScript 2.8, ich verlinke es mal
Anyway, also ich habe
damit mal rumgespielt und nach der letzten Folge
nachdem ich das schon mal erzählt habe, fand das eigentlich ganz cool
und ich habe auf Arbeit
gerade ein kleines Projekt, wo wir was parsen
und dann kommt da, wir haben einen externen Parser
der in JavaScript geschrieben ist.
Und da kommt dann so ein JSON-Objekt raus,
was nicht wirklich typisiert ist.
Oder, ich meine, das ist halt pures JavaScript.
Ich möchte aber damit,
ich muss damit dann intern relativ viel machen.
Deswegen habe ich mir ein Beispiel angeguckt
und habe dafür erstmal Type-Definitionen geschrieben.
Und jetzt kriege ich das aus dem Parser rausgespuckt
und ich möchte das Type-Script mir garantiert,
zur Laufzeit, dass das wirklich diese Struktur hat.
Und das geht nicht wirklich.
Was du jetzt machst, ist, dass du dich hinsetzt
und einmal habe ich händisch diese
Type-Definition geschrieben
und jetzt kannst du dich hinsetzen
und kannst diese Type-Guards
selber schreiben.
Das ist gerade bei so einem komplexen,
verschachtelten Typen wie dem, was wir da gepasst haben,
relativ tedious, weil das ist
irgendwie ein Objekt mit fünf geschachtelten
Unterobjekten, das sind große Interfaces,
die irgendwie fünf
bis zehn Properties haben, die selber noch
eigene komplexe Typen haben.
Das ist ein richtig großes, geschachteltes Typ.
Da kommt schon was Besonderes.
Und da kannst du dich jetzt hinsetzen
und für jeden Typen schreiben
is this type.
Das kriegt dann any rein.
Dann machst du da if
returns true
und der Rückgabetyp davon ist
halt nicht boolean, sondern
argument is
type name.
Wenn du das benutzt, dann glaubt dir der
Compiler wie gesagt hinterher, dass das von dem Typen ist.
Ich habe gedacht, das ist
ziemlich tedious.
Und ich dachte, Typescript hat doch eine API.
Und da habe ich,
es war gar nicht so schwer,
es hat vielleicht so zwei Abende gedauert,
da habe ich mir einen Code-Generator
für Typeguards gebaut.
Witzig, okay.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt ein kleines Tool,
das heißt GuardGen, habe ich auf GitHub,
vielleicht muss ich noch ein bisschen mehr daran arbeiten,
aber ich verlinke es mal in den Shownotes.
Da schmeißt du
eine TypeScript-Datei mit Interfaces rein
und der generiert dir
TypeScript-Code, wo du
Objekte von diesem Interface oder von jedem
Interface reinstecken kannst und der dir dann
sagt, ob es das wirklich ist. Und wenn du diese Funktion
in deinem Code verwendest, kannst du
hinterher darauf auch in der IDE
arbeiten, als wäre es von diesem Typen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice. Finde ich cool.
Gefällt mir. Genau.
Dinge automatisieren. Immer
eine super Idee. Ja, ich
habe echt groß gestaunt, dass
es das noch nicht gab.
Aber die TypeScript
Compiler API hat sich wahrscheinlich,
die ist noch nicht komplett stabil, deswegen
Zumindest hat sich noch keiner reingetraut, sowas, sowas.
Das hat sich vielleicht einfach noch keiner getraut.
Genau. Deswegen habe ich es auch direkt
schon vor zwei Wochen auf der
TypeScript 3.0 Beta
gemacht. Ich hoffe, dass die dann jetzt
einigermaßen stabil bleibt erstmal.
Und wann hältst du die ersten Talks darüber?
Irgendwelche TypeScript-Cons?
Also ich hatte eigentlich vor, mich von der Firma
nächstes Jahr zur JS-Conf schicken zu lassen.
Ist doch ideal geeignet. Das ist natürlich noch ein Jahr hin,
aber bis dahin habe ich bestimmt einen Talk drüber geschrieben.
Dein Polish-Talk schreiben?
Ich kann ja vielleicht mal hier auf dem
JS-Meetup in Dresden...
Die ersten 1000 Stars sammeln.
Oh, die ersten 1000 Stars. Was sind denn die
meisten Stars, die du auf einem Projekt hast? Ich bin ja hier
noch Kleinkünstler auf GitHub.
Ich habe bei einem Projekt
140 Stars oder sowas.
Das ist schon extrem viel.
Ich habe 150 bei einem, aber nur das eine.
Das ist so dieser
Sea-Rise-Spinner für Swift.
Der ist natürlich auch echt chic.
Den komplett geklaut.
den Code 1 zu 1 kopiert
aus dem JavaScript von
Sintra Sohoes zu Swift gemacht
und fertig.
Volle Sau.
Aber ich wollte sowas haben.
Ne, sehr cool.
Gerade den muss ich mir nochmal anschauen.
Genau, vielleicht könnte man das mal auf
ein anderes Projekt werfen, wo wir gerade bei
Good News sind.
Springen wir doch mal gleich zu den Projekten.
Du meinst so andere Sachen, die in TypeScript geschrieben wurden?
Ja, genau. Wo seit kurzer Zeit in TypeScript
geschrieben sind? Nämlich
DVB-TS, äh, JS.
Ich finde, das Video müsste doch umbenannt werden.
Kleine Notiz an den Andi.
Benenn das Projekt mal um.
Also, wovon reden wir? DVB...
DVB-TS, äh, JS.
Danke für den Trigger.
Ist ein JavaScript-Module, was ich vor einer Zeit lang mal geschrieben habe.
Mittlerweile vor,
mal nachschauen, es müssten drei Jahre so sein.
2014.
Genau, 2014.
Ja, es sind drei Jahre. Kann ich gut rechnen.
Das kam so aus der Bewegung raus.
Jeder schreibt ein Catch-My-Buzz.
Genau. Und ich wollte ein Tool haben,
mit dem ich sehen kann,
genauso wie bei dir auch damals in deinem Ruby-Skript,
wann der letzte Bus kommt,
den ich noch erwischen kann.
Und nachdem ich mich ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt hatte
mit der API von der DVB,
z.B. VVO, habe ich das Ganze mal
in JavaScript-Module gepackt. Fand ich damals super cool.
Hat nicht viel gemacht.
Und es nutzen tatsächlich Leute.
Ein paar Leute nutzen es sogar so sehr,
dass in den Issues kommentiert wird.
Wir haben ein Gehtmiss endlich mit der neuen API,
weil da gab es lange mal eine Phase, wo es nicht ging,
weil die DVB-Überziehung der VVO
oder was umgestellt hatte. Und der Andy
hat da sehr, sehr viel
mittlerweile daran gearbeitet und
einen PR fertig gemacht, vor einer ganzen
Weile schon. Der PR, also
klassischer Complete Rewrite PR, oder?
Das ist ein komplett Convert
zu TypeScript gewesen mittlerweile und er hat ihn
jetzt gemerged und er ist super cool und ich habe es mir
schon mal angeschaut und es gefällt mir sehr.
Das ist ein dicker PR.
Was hat der für ein Change Set?
16.000 Editions
Das sind aber auch...
Wie viele Commits sind da drin?
58.
Der wollte echt bloß deinen Repo
für sein eigenes Projekt benutzen, kann das sein?
Können wir es gleich zu ihm rübertransführen.
Er hat aber vorher auch irgendwie acht Issues aufgemacht
und die der Reihe nach in den PR abgehakt.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr cool.
Andi ist da sehr professionell, was das angeht.
Ja, vor allem, weil ich an dem Repo schon lange nichts mehr gemacht habe.
Ich verstehe die aktuelle Architektur auch.
Ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht, muss ich mir mal einarbeiten.
Ich habe mit TypeScript und JavaScript
quasi noch nie wirklich was gemacht.
mit JavaScript schon so lange nicht mehr.
Aber es sieht super cool aus,
gefällt mir sehr und
kann man benutzen. Das wird auch tatsächlich
von ein paar Leuten genutzt für
diverse Projekte. Finde ich sehr angenehm.
Für die paar Alexa-Skills und
ich glaube, der ist irgend so ein
Facebook-Chatbot und so weiter.
Cool. Also ich habe einen Kollegen,
der schon,
der saß bei mir, also der ist nicht direkt mit mir
im Team, aber der sitzt immer im gleichen Raum
und der hat dann irgendwie irgendwann mal
angefangen, über Amazon Echo zu reden,
bevor, also
kurz nachdem die rausgekommen sind, hat gesagt, ja, ich
habe mir jetzt so einen Teil geholt und das macht Spaß und ich
baue mir da Skills und die kann man auf Amazon
Lambda, da kannst du ja einfach einrichten,
das ist einfach nur das JavaScript und da kannst du halt
so Sachen machen, wie ich frage das Ding
halt, ich sage, lass mich das erinnern,
wann der nächste mal was
an meiner Haltestelle kommt, da gibt es Sachen,
also was die Leute in JavaScript alles schreiben,
DVBJS,
krass, und ich so,
den Typen, der das gemacht hat, den kenne ich,
Und der Typ, der das jetzt geerbt hat, der arbeitet jetzt auch bei uns.
Oh ne.
Und wer benutzt noch so alles? Weißt du das?
Nicht wirklich das einzige, was ich mal gehört habe.
Das fand ich sehr, sehr cool.
Das war auf den Datenspuren von vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich.
Da gab es einen Hackathon von der Stadt, unter anderem vom VVO.
Und die haben da Sachen mitgebracht.
Die haben Daten mitgebracht.
Wir haben da mal was vorbereitet.
Ja, wir haben so ein Korb voller Daten dabei.
haben die auf den Tisch gekippt. Nicht Spaß, die haben
ihre Schnittstellen mitgebracht und
haben Leuten entscheidend kurz gezeigt, wie
die funktionieren.
Und niemand hat
die wirklich nutzen wollen. Die meisten Leute
haben halt direkt die VBGS
reingezogen und das benutzt.
Und ja, war wohl sehr witzig.
Das ist wirklich auch schon wieder bis hinher.
Viel mehr habe ich einfach nicht mitbekommen.
Ich finde es bei Eichendrucken, wenn ich hier gerade das Repo
aufmache, dann steht hier in der einen Badge
hier 224 Downloads per Month.
Das sind bestimmt alle Leute,
die NPM auch mirroren mit dabei, oder?
Ja, die NPM-Downloads,
die sind,
da ist eher die erste Ableitung von interessant.
Achso, ich werde jetzt jetzt ein Zehntel erstmal genommen,
aber gut, ja.
Ich habe tatsächlich bei einem,
ich habe ja
mehr Rust-Crates veröffentlicht
als NPM-Packages.
Und ich habe irgendwann mal...
Du hast mehr Rust-Crates veröffentlicht, als es NPM-Packages gibt?
Nein, als ich NPM-Packages veröffentlicht habe.
Bei diesem GuardGen und bei einem anderen Projekt,
wo ich so lazy Iteratoren in TypeScript gebaut habe,
überlege ich noch, ob ich das wirklich veröffentlichen soll.
Dann hätte ich tatsächlich mal was auf NPM veröffentlicht,
dafür, dass ich professionell mit JavaScript arbeite.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel mal einen Rust-Crate veröffentlicht,
weil ich mich gefunden habe, ich habe hier,
boah, ich habe schon tausend Downloads auf meinem Crate.
Wie viel davon ist wo echt und wie viel nicht?
Also bei Crate.io ist es wirklich so,
dass da die Zahlen noch sehr aussagekräftig sind.
Ich habe eins veröffentlicht.
ich sag jetzt nicht genau, wie es heißt,
weil es auch nicht mehr genau aus dem Kopf heißt,
aber das heißt sowas wie
Baseline Crate
und da steht einfach drin, dieses Crate macht nichts
und es kann auch nichts
und bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte,
bitte benutzt es nirgendwo
und dann kann man sich nämlich die Downloadzahlen
von dem Ding angucken, dann siehst du, wie viele Leute
einfach bloß
das System mirroren
komplett, die einfach alles ziehen.
Baseline.
Achso.
Ich wette, nachdem diese Folge raus ist, ist es kaputt.
Dann können wir die Download-Zahlen hoch.
Ja, weil wir jetzt
zigtausende Hörer haben, die
alles so Spaß vorgenommen haben.
Wie viele haben die letzte Folge runtergeladen?
Laut unserem Host sind es, glaube ich,
um die 100.
Top 10
Episodes, da muss ich jetzt zu Folge
20 schauen. 103.
103 Leute haben von Squirting und anderen
Lesetechniken bisher gedownloadet.
Cool. Finde ich cool.
Also vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr uns immer noch hört.
Ich habe auch letztens mit irgendjemandem gesprochen, der meinte, sie meinte, er meinte,
ich hätte überhaupt nicht gehört, wer das war,
ich glaube, sie meinte zu mir, dass sie unseren Podcast hört.
Ist jetzt bei Folge 2.
Krass.
Vorne angefangen.
Nicht schlecht.
Naja, bei so 20-Folgigen Podcasts kann man das noch machen.
Ich habe jetzt unsere erste Folge nochmal reingehört.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Wir haben uns jetzt schon voll entwickelt.
Ich habe, nachdem ich die letzte Folge geschnitten habe,
habe ich die ganzen Anfänge nochmal gehört.
Aber das habe ich extra auf Spotify
gemacht, weil ich weiß, dass das nicht in die Statistik
mit reinzieht. Man kann uns übrigens auch auf Spotify
hören. Das könnt ihr durchaus machen.
Wenn ihr das macht,
bitte abonniert uns mit irgendwas anderem trotzdem,
damit wir die Zahlen... Ach Quatsch,
ob die es jetzt real sind oder nicht, ist ja wurscht.
Aber man kann uns hören auf Spotify, wenn man denn möchte.
Viel lieber noch direkt erst download aus dem Feed
oder auch sehr cool über
wie heißt die BitTorren-Plattform?
Über Bitlove. Über Bitlove kann man das auch hören.
Das finde ich noch mal
drei Schritte cooler.
Genau, wenn ihr einen BitTorrent-fähigen
Podcast-Client habt.
Stimmt, das ist nicht so weit verbreitet,
aber trotzdem technisch cool.
Nee, weiter,
wir haben noch ein paar Good News,
everybody. Wollen wir das abwechselnd
machen oder wollen wir das
erst nur die Good News und dann
nur die Bad News? Ach, wir haben nur noch eine Good News.
Stimmt. Und zwar
habe ich eine Seite geupdatet, von
der ich nicht erwartet hätte, dass ich sie jemals in meinem Leben
nochmal updaten darf.
Is Apple Pay available in Germany yet.com?
Genau.
Und da stand bisher immer ein großes dickes Nein.
Und vor ein paar Tagen kam die Aussage,
it's coming.
Und jetzt steht da,
soon, fingers crossed, Emoji.
Genau.
Und zwar hat Apple angekündigt,
dass Apple Pay nicht nach Deutschland kommen wird.
Das finde ich super cool.
Weil Apple Pay es nicht nur für mich
sehr angenehm machen wird, damit zu zahlen.
aber online vor allem auch viel
naja, sicherer im Sinne von
wenn ich irgendwo online mit Apple Pay zahlen kann
kann ich direkt mit meinem Bankkonto
slash Apple zahlen und nicht mehr mit
irgendeinem scheiß Provider wie PayPal
und das verbreitet sich immer mehr
und das coole an Apple Pay ist, wenn du damit
deine Karten zahlst, Apple Pay generiert dir
für jede Transaktion eine neue Kreditkartennummer
Wollte gerade sagen, tut Apple Pay
nicht eigentlich nur so, als wäre es
eine Kreditkarte? Ja
Das heißt, was jetzt in den letzten
Monaten sich doch mehr verbreitet hat.
In Deutschland ist Contactless
Payment, dass du einfach...
Achso, du meinst, ob das nur Kredit... Nee, Apple Pay kann mittlerweile
auch Debitcards. Ich meine bloß,
für das Gerät,
das Gerät sollte doch eigentlich nicht erkennen können, ob es
den Unterschied erkennen können, ob es ein Telefon
mit Apple Pay ist oder eine Kreditkarte, oder?
Nee, das ist NFC. Ergo,
alle Geräte, wo du jetzt Contactless
mit einer Kreditkarte zahlen kannst, kannst
du mittlerweile eigentlich theoretisch auch schon mit Apple Pay
bezahlen, oder? Technisch ja, bloß, dass es
halt in Deutschland nicht möglich ist.
Das heißt, Sie können doch erkennen,
dass es keine echte Kreditkarte ist?
Nee, du kannst dir als deutscher Kunde kein Apple Pay Konto einrichten
und deine Karten nicht verknüpfen.
Achso, das ist einfach Apple-seitig für deutsche Kunden abgestellt.
Genau, weil keine deutsche Bank mit Apple bisher kooperiert hat,
um den Supporter für einzubauen.
Und die erste Bank, die das macht,
sag ich mal, es gäbe nur eine, die das macht,
die wird einen unglaublichen Kundenzuwachs bekommen,
das verspreche ich dir.
Also jede Bank, die sie dagegen wehrt,
immer noch auf ihre eigene dumme Insellösung setzt.
Hallo Sparkasse, das ist einfach dumm.
Die Sparkasse ist keine Bank, werden sie dir sagen.
Ja, super. Trotzdem
sehen es genug Künder anders.
Ich habe auch noch ein Konto bei der Sparkasse
und ich habe auch ein Konto bei der GLS Bank,
die auch schon öffentlich gesagt haben,
dass sie das erstmal nicht mehr unterstützen werden, weil ich das schade finde.
Bei der GLS werde ich auch bleiben,
weil ich die ethisch sehr cool finde, aber ich würde
trotzdem das Sparkassenkonto sofort kündigen für die erste
für eine Bank, die das kann,
weil ich will das nutzen.
Und wenn ich da eine Bank finde, die das technisch sauber umsetzt,
das ist eine Nummer 26, dann weiß ich nicht.
Die sind jetzt wirklich eine Bank, ne?
Die sind mittlerweile eine Bank, aber
die sind ja mittlerweile hoffentlich auch sicher,
in Anführungszeichen, aber
das, was sie damals abgeliefert haben, dieser Shut-up
and Take-my-Money-Talk vom Kongo ist von 34,
32, 33, 33? 34, glaube ich.
Einer von denen.
Der Talk war große Klasse,
aber so erschreckend für diese Bank.
Also der Talk, ehrlich gesagt,
hat bei mir dafür gesorgt, dass ich den Eindruck habe,
dass die systemische Probleme haben und wahrscheinlich,
wenn sie nicht alles von vorne
bauen und komplett
neue Teams einstellen, dass sie wahrscheinlich
immer noch die gleichen Probleme haben werden.
Die hatten halt null Fokus auf Security gelegt.
Wenn du solche Fehler machst, klar kannst du die fixen.
Die waren auch gefixt, als sie den Talk gehalten hat.
Die haben den Typen, der den Talk gehalten hat,
eingeladen, um Workshops zu halten, intern,
damit er denen erklärt, was Sicherheit
überhaupt ist. Und wenn du halt überhaupt
nur eine Bank bist und du hast
einfach mal...
Die hatten zwei Sachen, die ich besonders geil fand.
Zum einen, wenn du
dein Passwort zurückvergessen hast, dann kannst du
über ein Formular dein Passwort zurücksetzen
und dann kriegst du eine Mail mit einem Passwort zurücksetzen-Link.
Kennt man, gängige Praxis.
Blöderweise haben die aus mir
absolut unerfindlichen Gründen, vielleicht zum Debuggen
anfangs, in der Response
vom Server, wo du das Formular
abgeschickt hast und das Passwort zurücksetzen,
ebenfalls den Passwort zurücksetzen-Link mit reingepackt,
sodass die Person den zwar per E-Mail bekommen hat,
du aber auch, wenn du jemand anderes
bist, den Link schon direkt in der Hand hattest,
sprich, wenn ich die E-Mail-Adresse von einem Benutzer
kenne, von Number26, konnte ich direkt
dir sein Passwort zurücksetzen und übernehmen das
Account. Ohne das, also der kriegt
das halt natürlich mit, weil er eine Mail bekommt, aber
das Passwort ist schon zu spät.
Das ist so unglaublich bescheuert.
Das passiert ja auch nicht aus Versehen.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich wirklich aus Debuggründen
drin gehabt und dann vergessen. Kann man sich eigentlich mit deinem
Passwortmanager auch random
E-Mail-Adressen generieren lassen?
Das wäre ein cooles Plugin.
Das überlege ich manchmal, wenn du dich irgendwo mit
Benutzernamen und Passwort einloggst.
Viele Leute leiden ja dazu, immer wieder den gleichen
Benutzernamen zu nehmen. Eigentlich ist
genauso Teil deines Passworts.
Ob du den nur einfach nimmst und vorne
an dein Passwort rankongatenierst
oder ob du nur ein Passwort nimmst, ist eigentlich voll egal.
Das wäre gar nicht so unklapp, vor allem weil viele Services
das wäre gar nicht mal so
unklapp, weil zum Beispiel Services wie Gmail
sogar dieses Feature haben, dass du mit einem Plus
Random Strings rankongatenieren kannst
an deine, also Name plus irgendwas
at gmail.com und viele andere
können das auch. Bei meinem
Mail-Server geht das ebenso, beziehungsweise
du unterstützt der E-Mail-Standard ja sogar Kommentare
in Klammern, wusstest du das?
In der E-Mail-Adresse oder was? Ja, du kannst in der E-Mail-Adresse
mit Klammern einen Kommentar reinpacken.
Die meisten E-Mail-Parser gehen nachher ran kaputt, aber
im RFC ist es gelistet als
Feature. Die meisten E-Mail-Parser gehen nachher ran kaputt.
Ich weiß, dass ich irgendwo mal
einen E-Mail-Parser eingebaut habe.
Was war denn das? Ach, die Ruby-Variante
von dem ASCII-Invulsor.
Da habe ich mal geguckt, E-Mail-Validierung
in Ruby, wollte ich mir irgendwo
rauskopieren. Im Endeffekt, was ich gefunden habe,
wo dann auf Stack Overflow dran stand,
ja, das ist RFC-kompatibel.
Das war irgendwie so ein 20
Ja, das willst du auch meistens halt nicht.
Du kannst halt so viel falsch machen
dabei und Leute, die haben halt, das ist so viel
Blackmagic-E-Mails zu validieren. Idealerweise
willst du einfach mal schauen, ist ein Ad-Zeichen drin, das war's.
Ah, da muss ich jetzt echt mal gucken, ob das bei mir vielleicht auch geht.
Ich habe eigentlich, ich benutze
eigentlich auch unterschiedliche E-Mail-Adressen für
unterschiedliche Dienste und dann habe ich aber
irgendwie keinen Bock. Eigentlich möchte ich
meinen Catch-all-E-Mail
wieder abschalten, weil ich
mittlerweile eine Whitelist pflege und alles andere
in den Spam-Order kommt.
Und dann kriege ich irgendwie jede Spam 35 Mal
an unterschiedliche
Ad meiner Domain.
Und wenn es einfach gehen würde,
dass ich dann einfach meine normale E-Mail-Adresse
mit in Klammern das und das
nehmen könnte und dann daran,
dass es Unterordner soziert ist.
Das werden die meisten Services aber nicht unterstützen.
Aber du kannst sagen, der Plus-Trick müsste bei den meisten anderen Servern auch funktionieren.
Vielleicht geht das bei dir genauso.
Und nochmal zurück, E-Mail-Validierung.
Was wollte ich da gerade sagen?
Facken.
Nee, nicht so weit zurück.
Gmail.
Achso, nee, nochmal einen Schritt zurück.
Thema E-Mail-Validierung.
Letztens ein Account bei DHL anlegen wollen.
Nee, meine E-Mail-Adresse ist nicht valide.
DHL.
Bei DHL, genau.
Meine E-Mail-Adresse ist nicht valide.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es eine IO-TLD ist,
aber weil sie IO als TLD hat,
aber nö, IO-Domains gehen nicht.
Nach ein bisschen hin und her
konnte ich mit einer anderen Adresse eins anlegen
und die dann ändern.
Fuck, total dumm.
oder noch besser Services, wo du dich anmeldest.
Meine E-Mail-Adresse fängt mit me an,
also me-ad und Services,
die einfach mal davon ausgehen, dass das vor dem Ad
immer dein Username ist und dann so, hello me.
Nein, so heiße ich
nicht.
Aber dann würden sie jeden anderen mit
hello Hendrik.soll ich ansprechen?
Ja, wenn man das klappt bei den ganzen
Gmail-Nutzern oder so.
Ja, um den Stack noch mal ein bisschen weiter zu
anwinden.
Number 26 ist eine andere, weil ich noch ansprechen wollte,
weil ich das immer noch super kacke fand, wenn ich das nicht falsche
Erinnerung habe aus dem Talk, war, dass die
in ihrer App, in ihrer iOS-App
relativ früh den Series-Support mit
einbauen wollten, weil das super cool ist
von der Idee her, dass du sagst, hey
Assistent, schick mal
so und so viel Geld an so und so
via N26
oder Nr26 oder Nr26
ich weiß nicht, wie war es, wie war es, die Serie da triggern muss, wie die App
auf iOS heißt. N26. N26
vermutlich.
Und das Feature finde ich das super cool.
Dann geht es schon ein Pop-up auf von UI und
du schaust dir die Beträgen nochmal an und bestätigst
das Theorie nochmal, passt, wunderbar.
Und das wollten sie ja in der App drin haben, anscheinend
fanden die es aber zu schwer, darüber
Authentication zu basteln, deswegen
gab es da wohl einen Endpoint, einen API-Endpoint
bei denen irgendwie slash unverified
und da hast du drei Sachen hingeschickt, von wem an
wen, wie viel. Das war's.
Das war's.
Und sie haben natürlich dann gesagt,
dass sie ja durch schlaue Algorithmen
und so prüfen, dass da niemand Jindlu
damit treibt. Und dann hat er in dem Talk mal
spaßenshalber über ein paar Stunden hinweg
jede Sekunde einen Cent von einem Konto
an das andere überwiesen.
Das ging halt.
Das erinnert mich an den
BTX-Hack, wofür der
Chaos Computer Club am Anfang berühmt geworden ist.
Verdammt.
Und zwar war das irgendwie,
die genaue Geschichte findet ihr auf
Chaos Radio Express,
in der Geschichte des Chaos Computer Clubs.
Da hatten sie zumindest
eine Bankeninterface,
ein BTX-Interface in den 80ern.
BTX ist halt so eine kleine Vorstufe des Internets
von der Deutschen Post gewesen.
Damals, als die Deutsche Post
quasi noch die Telekom-Post war,
und
die hatten,
da hast du,
da konntest du eine Replay-Attacke fahren.
Die hatten quasi eine Überweisung
über dieses
Protokoll gemacht
und dadurch, dass es alles über das Telefon lief,
konntest du es einfach mit einem,
mit einer Kassette aufzeichnen
und dann haben sie das
in der Schleife laufen lässt, so eine Nacht lang.
Es war halt ein bisschen teuer, weil die mussten die ganze Nacht
telefonieren.
Hatten damit aber irgendwie
mehrere 10.000
Mark von einem Konto
auf ein anderes überwiesen.
Nee, also das war noch irgendwas anderes, womit sie dann überhaupt
das Geld überweisen konnten.
Nee, super cool. Warum nicht?
Muss mir den BTX halt nochmal genau durchlesen,
was sie da wirklich gemacht haben.
Genau.
Cool, gute Neuigkeiten. Wir hatten bei Apple Pay
angefangen. Achso, ja, um den Stack noch
Runde weiter zu entwinden. Wir haben ja schon bei
Number26 waren gerade. Die
ING Holland, also die ING-DiBa
Äquivalent, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie die Firma
irgendwie zusammenhört, aber wohl irgendwie zusammen.
INGL. Genau so heißen die auf Twitter.
INGL. I-N-G-N-L.
Die haben so einen schönen Tweet rausgehauen. Erinnerst du dich noch
an die Kette von Telekom Österreich?
Ja. Das ist
selbes Level hier. Hier hat einer gefragt,
INGL, why can I not use my password
manager on the ING login page? Me copy
pasting my credentials can't be much added security.
haben sie geschrieben, hi, good to contact us.
Due to the new technology, we no longer support the Password Manager.
We also strongly recommend not to use of a Password Manager for your own safety.
Und da gab es dann auf Twitter ein bisschen Backlash.
Dann geht es los.
Von wegen hier total bekloppt.
Ja, und die argumentieren halt, dass Password Manager halt nicht secure sind,
weil sie können generell nicht alle auditen davon.
Und deswegen können sie es lieber gar keinen benutzen.
Die haben irgendwie auf ihrer Webseite unterbunden,
dass du einen Password Manager benutzen kannst?
Ein bisschen später revidieren sie das noch ein bisschen.
Was sie gemacht haben, ist, also sie argumentieren
auch dafür, dass Passwortmanager tatsächlich gut sein können,
aber sie haben auf der Webseite unterbunden,
dass der Browser sich das Passwort merken kann.
Ah, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es geht.
Wusste ich auch nicht.
Ach, das kannst du, der Browser merkte das, glaube ich,
anhand von dem Formularfeld.
Ah, clever, also machst du das Passwortfeld,
kein Passwortfeld, sondern Klartextfeld und dann
macht das nicht?
Vielleicht?
Nee, das war jetzt hoffentlich nicht ernst gemeint.
Aber du könntest die IDs von den Dingern irgendwie randomisen
und auf die Art und Weise dem Browser halt sagen,
vorgaukeln, dass es jedes Mal ein komplett neues
Problem ist. Das heißt, er speichert sich immer mehr dazu.
Wahrscheinlich, du kannst irgendwie 35.000 Mal
safe Passworts machen.
Das wäre ja dumm.
Nee, eigentlich, der Browser macht das schon
mit der Heuristik und schaut dann,
hier ist irgendein Passwortfeld.
Noch viel cleverer. Du kannst, glaube ich, da einen Flagg setzen.
Du machst das zu einem normalen Textfeld,
aber jedes Mal, wenn der Nutzer Input reingibt,
er löscht den Text und setzt ihn mit
Punktzeichen in JavaScript.
Du kannst dir ein Passwortfeld auch komplett
mit CSS nachbauen.
Damit hast du halt keinen Schutz vor dem...
Das ist eine Scheißidee.
Das ist eine Scheißidee,
weil das Passwortfeld tatsächlich verhindert, dass du es wieder
rauskopierst. Du kannst
bei einem normalen Textfeld kannst du das alles markieren,
kopieren und irgendwo anders hin pasten
und bei einem Passwortfeld kannst du das
hoffentlich nicht. Also ich denke mal,
das war der Sinn von dem Passwortfeld.
Ich gehe davon aus, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal probiert,
da gehe ich es zumindest nicht, aber ich will sowas auch nicht
ja, was Crypto oder CSS irgendwie durch Magic gelöst haben,
das sollen einfach ganz ordentliche Standardfeatures
sein und wenn ich will, dass mein Browser
sich das für meine Bank merkt, dann soll das so sein.
außer ich bin bei der Sparkasse und habe mein Passwort
eh als eine fünfstellige fucking Zahl.
Das kann ich mir auch selber merken.
Da brauche ich keine Hilfe für fünf Zahlenanfänger.
Das kann man aber wahrscheinlich auch durch irgendeine IT ersetzen.
Ja, durch alles andere außer...
Ich meine, diese PIN ist wahrscheinlich noch ein Überbleibsel
und du hast wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Untermaske bei deiner Bankseite
die Möglichkeit, das durch einen sicheren Login zu ersetzen
und denen? Nö, nicht bei meiner Sparkasse.
Ah, okay. Da ist der Login ausschließlich
über Kontonummer, die ist quasi Public Knowledge.
Also ihr wisst jetzt, dass Kilian bei der Sparkasse ist?
Aber nicht bei welcher, es gibt ja zigtausend.
Ihr wisst, dass wir ein Podcast aus Dresden
sind? Bin ich bei der Ostsächsischen.
Ihr wisst jetzt, dass er nicht bei der Ostsächsischen
ist? Immer noch 1999.
Und ihr habt jetzt 10.000
Versuche.
Mir ist das so dumm,
meine Kontonummer ist quasi Public Knowledge, die sieht ja
jeder, dem ich was überweise. Nicht 10.000, 100.000
Versuche. Und mein Passwort
eine fünfstellige Zahl.
Und zwar geht das auch nur als Zahl. Natürlich kannst du dich
anmelden und nichts machen, weil dann brauchst du eine TAN.
Aber du kannst trotzdem meine gesamte Konto-History
einsehen. Und das will ich nicht, dass das eine Möglichkeit
darstellt. Das gehört sich nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn ich meine Sparkasse mal angerufen habe, um eine Zahlung
rückgängig zu machen, rufe ich an. Ja, Kölsch am Telefon.
Ich würde gerne eine Zahlung so und so rückgängig machen.
Ja, okay, Sekunde, ich schau mal kurz rein.
Meinen Sie die ganz oben von der so und so?
Ich habe Ihnen bis jetzt nur gesagt, wie ich heiße.
Aber ja, genau, die meine ich.
Können Sie das bitte nicht
einfach so am Telefon sagen?
Damit sind wir eigentlich quasi direkt in die
Bad News Section abgedriftet, oder?
Können wir noch irgendwie...
Wir müssen uns noch was Positives für später aufhören.
Ich glaube, wir haben hier noch was Positives für später.
Ja, kurz
Bad News, wo wir jetzt immer dabei sind.
Also einer unserer Lieblings-Podcasts
Oh ja, das habe ich auch gehört.
Also das heißt, hören die auf?
Jetzt geht es um den Bike Chat,
die wir beide sehr gerne hören. Genau,
Bike Chat ist auch so ein bisschen das englischsprachige Vorbild
für das, was wir hier machen. Ja, genau.
Was heißt denn die Hören auf? Die beiden sind
Sean und wie heißt der andere? Sean und Derek.
Sean und Derek. So, die Geschichte ist,
bikechat.fm ist
ein Thoughtbot Podcast.
Thoughtbot ist so eine Rails-Consultancy.
Eine ziemlich coole Rails-Consultancy.
Die machen das, genau, und die Leute,
die machen auch, die haben auch
Blogs oder die encouragen ihre Leute zu
bloggen und zu publishen.
Und die haben halt diesen Podcast organisiert und quasi produzieren und hosten die das auf Firmenkosten.
Und die Leute, die da reden, die machen das halt zu ihrer Arbeitszeit.
Nun ist es so, dass kurz nachdem dieser Podcast mit Sean und Derek,
Sean ist der Entwickler von Diesel zum Beispiel.
Und Contributor bei Rale.
Ja genau, der ist Contributor bei Active Record.
Nun ist es so, dass Sean irgendwie kurz nachdem die mit dem Podcast gemeinsam angefangen haben,
eigentlich bei Thoughtbot aufgehört hat
und bei Shopify arbeitet und die einfach
den Podcast trotzdem so weitergemacht
haben, weil Derek ja noch bei
Thoughtbot ist. Jetzt ist es so, dass Derek
von Thoughtbot zu GitHub wechselt
und quasi Thoughtbot einen Podcast hosten würde,
wo nicht einer von Thoughtbot
arbeitet, von den Hosts.
Und deswegen
rehosten sie den jetzt quasi.
Die machen den Podcast weiter,
aber es gibt andere Hosts. Sean ist raus.
Die haben jetzt auch so eine etwas
emotionale
Folge gemacht, aber witzigerweise
die nächste Folge war schon wieder mit Derek, aber mit
einem anderen Host, der Derek sowas interviewt hat.
Wahrscheinlich war das auch so eine, wir reden,
wir machen jetzt nochmal eine Folge mit dir
als Gast und danach bist du aber wirklich raus.
Ist ja nicht falsch. Vor allem, weil zumindest
Sean oder beide zusammen machen ja noch in unserem neuen Podcast
vielleicht mit dem Jagshaving Podcast
weiter. Großartige Namen.
Vom BikeShat zum
Jagshaving.
Da habe ich mich auch gewundert, dass der Name noch zu haben war.
Ja, das hätte ich nicht erwartet.
Warum haben wir den nicht genommen?
The Yak Shave.
Dann hätte es dann
gewiesen, ja, ich wollte eigentlich einen neuen Podcast
machen, The Yak Shave, aber den haben
ja schon zwei deutsche Teams
gemacht.
Das wäre unsere Chance gewesen.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, den Namen tatsächlich im Kopf,
als wir uns für unseren Podcast den Namen ausgedacht haben,
weil ich dachte, The Bike Shad, The Yak Shave.
Da dachte ich mir, nee, das ist
zu sehr abgekoppelt. Dementsprechend passt es eigentlich,
dass die den Namen jetzt weiter.
Nee, aber was ich auch sehr witzig
fand aus dem Podcast, war
die Erzählung, dass es wohl ein Slack-Team
für Ex-Thought-Bot-Mitarbeiter
gibt, und zwar nur für Leute, die dort
nicht mehr arbeiten und
dass man doch nicht aufhören sollte, nur um diesem Slack-Team
einzutreten, egal wie toll das angeblich sein soll.
Ach, weil dann nur Ex
rein dürfen. Finde ich sehr witzig.
Ja, du musst
schon bei der Firma kündigen, um in diesen Channel
reingelassen zu werden. Ein sehr elitärer. Obwohl ich mich
frage, wie sie das machen bei uns, wenn Leute aufhören, wir haben auch Slack,
dann verlieren die ja
ihren Mitarbeiter-Account und daran
ist es bei Slack gebunden. Wir müssen quasi einen neuen Slack-Account
dafür kriegen. Das ist ja ein anderer Slack und jeder Slack
hat eh einen eigenen Account. Achso, das ist quasi
nicht ein Channel in deren Form. Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist ein komplett eigenes Slack. Dann ist das was anderes.
Apropos Slack.
Hast du gehört, dass Slack
HipChat gekauft hat? Nee.
Ich habe es da unter
Optional reingeschrieben. Was?
Krass. Nee, habe ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen.
Nee. Aber es ist nicht
Atlassian übernommen.
Nee, die haben Atlassian HipChat abgekauft.
Aha.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen krass.
Okay.
Müssen Leute nach HipChat?
Ja, also der große Unterschied zwischen Slack und HipChat.
Doch, der riesige Unterschied war,
dass Slack über zwei MB GIFs inline anzeigen kann.
Und somit das Superior Product ist.
Also ich weiß, wenn du jemanden einen von diesen flackernden Papageien schickst,
dass du auf einem Mac den Lüfter ankriegst damit.
Einmal, wir haben so ein Hypnoto-Emoji da drin.
Also mal davon haben wir gesehen, dass...
Hallo Philipp, ich habe 50.000 davon eine Nachricht geschickt.
mein Slack ist eingefroren,
mein MacBook-Lüfter sind hoch,
das ganze System ist in die Knie gegangen.
Wir nennen das auf Arbeit auch Hover-Modus.
Hier ist so kalt drin,
ich erheiz mal die ganze Geburt.
Jetzt hieß mal mit euren
MacBooks aus.
Das klingt nämlich bei so einem
2015er MacBook, ich weiß nicht,
bei dem neueren wahrscheinlich genauso,
als ob das Ding gleich abhebt.
Hovercraft-Modus.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen Titel.
Ein signifikanter Unterschied ist, dass du, glaube ich, wie alle Atlassian-Produkte HipChat selber hosten kannst im Gegensatz zu Slack.
Stimmt.
Und bei manchen, gerade vielen deutschen Firmen, ist das eine zwingende Voraussetzung.
Ich kenne viele Leute, die bei anderen Firmen, die komplett nur in Deutschland sitzen, arbeiten, die zum Beispiel Autotoolieferer sind oder für die Autoindustrie arbeiten, die an anderen Auflagen, dass die für ihre Infrastruktur keine Third-Party-Anbieter nehmen dürfen.
die müssen quasi alles selber hosten,
was insofern blöd ist, weil du dann halt,
ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich
kosteneffektiver
ist, wenn du alles selber machst, weil du hast halt
Leute, die sich die ganze Zeit nur darum kümmern, dass diese
Infrastruktur läuft. Ja, aber kosteneffektiv ist das eine,
aber On-Premise ist halt bedeutend sicherer
als wenn es sonst wo irgendwie... Ja,
ja, genau. Also was heißt, es muss nicht sicherer
sein, aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser, als wenn irgendeine
Third-Party, so wie Slack,
erstmal theoretisch... Also wenn du eine deutsche Firma bist und
amerikanische Firmen generell nicht raus, dann
auf jeden Fall. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn du natürlich
irgendwie sowas selber hostest und das,
weil derjenige, der das
hostet, irgendwie auch noch ein E-Mail und noch
ein 5-Docker und was weiß ich, alles
betreut und noch ein Wugin oder so,
dann wird es wahrscheinlich dazu kommen, dass du,
bei uns ist das so, wir hosten unser eigenes
Bitbucket und da haben wir jetzt vor kurzem
mal ein Update auf die aktuelle Version
bekommen, die hat gleich drei Major-Versionen übersprungen.
Dann ist es halt so, dass das,
wenn du es selber gemacht hast, dann häufig brach liegt
und lange nicht aktualisiert wird. Das kann natürlich
sein, aber gerade als
Unternehmen, deine Infrastruktur auf
Servern zu haben, die nicht unter
amerikanischem Recht stehen, finde ich schon
ein großer Vorteil. Also ich fände es cool,
wie gesagt, es kleben ja noch einige Leute jetzt auf
HipChat. HipChat ist ja nicht schlecht, aber halt nicht
so geil wie Slack. Ist Slack geil?
Ich weiß nicht, nee, Slack ist auch...
Ich weiß nicht, das ist Slack, wenn du so gehörst, dass IBM
E-Mails
abschafft und komplett auf Slack umschreibt.
Sind die wahnsinnig? Was soll denn die Scheiße?
Ich möchte jetzt nicht Slack als Produkt
Condone, aber es ist irgendwie schon von
diesen Chatlösungen schon eine der angenehmsten.
Ja, sie schieben so ein paar Dinge nach vorne. Es ist schön,
dass es Slack gibt, aber ich würde gerne
haben, dass es was Besseres gibt,
was alle nutzen. Also es gibt auch vieles, was
besser ist, was technisch wirklich besser ist. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber Slack hat sich halt so
mittlerweile etabliert als das, was jeder nutzen muss.
Und jetzt habe ich hier 15.000 Slack-Teams,
in denen ich mitgeblieb bin. Das ist scheiße.
Also wenn Leute sagen,
hier, wir sind die So-und-So-Community oder die
So-und-So-Community kommt in unser Slack, da musst
du dich halt jetzt in 35 Slacks anmelden.
weil es war glaube ich auch auf Bike Chat
wo sie gesagt haben,
dass Slack jetzt, wenn du dich einloggst,
merkt, oh du bist mit der gleichen
E-Mail-Adresse bei so und so vier anderen Slacks auch
angemeldet, möchtest du dich da gleich mit einloggen?
Ja, ich kriege dieses Dropdown-Pass schon nicht mehr
auf mein Display. Genau.
Achso genau, Sean bei The Bike Chat
hat sich darüber beschwert, dass er sich dann erstmal eine Viertelstunde
aus 90% aller Slacks wieder ausloggen
musste auf seinem Telefon, weil er auf dem Telefon nur
dieses eine Slack haben wollte.
Nee, das ist echt schrecklich.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass sie so ein paar Dinge pushen.
So Emoji-Reactions auf Nachrichten finde ich wertvoll.
General Threads sind ein super Feature,
was viel mehr Chat-Protokolle haben können.
Ja, das ist halt,
meinst du Emoji-Reactions als Paul nutzen
oder Paul ist inline, weil das hat Slack nicht.
Das hat Slack.
Also dann haben wir das als Plugin.
Ja, Integrations sind auch ein Feature,
was ich gerne hätte, vielmehr.
Auf anderen Plattformen auch.
Was ich schade finde, ist, dass sie ihren
XMPP-Support eingestellt haben.
Und den IOC-Gateway auch.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist das halt was,
was dich runterzieht.
Wenn du Features anbieten willst, die da in dem Protokoll nicht...
Haben sie auch schon. Haben sie schon längst.
Die haben sie einfach rausgenommen dafür.
Sie haben die abgeschaltet, wahrscheinlich um Leute dazu zu pushen.
Die an Kleinen zu verwenden.
Das finde ich eklig.
Wenn du Leute dazu bewegen willst, dein Ding zu nutzen,
dann musst du halt wirklich
WorldGarden von Anfang bis Ende machen.
Matrixwechsel immer mehr.
Vielleicht habe ich ja noch ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass das sich durchsetzt.
vielleicht, wie wir es überhaupt angesprochen hatten,
die französische Regierung hat
auf Matrix gesetzt als
Kommunikationstool für diverses
Stellen, habe ich so
bekommen, wenn ich das
richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Und das finde ich super cool. Und die haben
dadurch finanzielle Unterstützung, die
pushen stark voran.
Haben die nicht sogar irgendwie so ein
PubSubHub oder sowas zum
Verbreiten der Wahlergebnisse oder sowas
genommen gehabt? Uh, sexy.
Ich habe das bloß mal am Rand gehört, ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Was haben wir? Wie heißt die Software nochmal? Wahl...
Das kannst du nicht vergleichen.
Oh, fuck. Ich habe den Namen vergessen seit dem Kongo schon wieder.
Schrecklich. Wahl irgendwas 10.
Ja.
PC-Wahl. PC-Wahl.
Das war...
Wenn man schon mit PC anfängt.
Du kannst das vielleicht heutzutage...
Die müssen Pups abkramen und Videlphi-Software.
Aus den 80ern.
Ist PC-Wahl wenigstens politically correct?
Politically correct Wahl.
Ich glaube, wir haben noch einen potenziellen Tief.
Okay, aber nie, Slack hat Hipjack gekauft, witzig.
Ja, also...
Na, sollen sie doch, meinetwegen.
Sollen sie doch, genau.
Gibt eh besseres.
Nee, mehr Bad News.
Hier stehen zwei Sachen mit Firefox drin.
Ja, Firefox stellt den RSS-Support aus.
Der RSS-Support heißt, dass du viel subscriben kannst in Firefox-Siri.
Du hast normalerweise, kannst du eine RSS-Datei, Adresse direkt in deiner Browser-Zelle aufmachen,
dann kriegst du, ich schmeiße einfach nur
ein RLS drauf und zeige mir das dann
als HTML. Das Feature nutzt sich sehr, sehr häufig,
weil Safari kann kein fucking XML anzeigen.
Genau, das ist schön und was du halt auch
machen kannst, ist, dass du
Live-Bookmarks abonnieren kannst, schon
seit Firefox 1, glaube ich.
Was das heißt, ist, dass du dir den
RSS-Feed als
Bookmark einrichtest oder sieht dann aus wie ein Bookmark,
das kannst du in deiner Bookmark-Leiste haben
und das verhält sich dann wie ein Ordner.
Wenn du draufklickst, geht das auf
und da sind die obersten... Also du weißt
nicht davon? Das wusste ich nicht, das Feature.
Das gibt es seit Firefox 1.0
und die schalten es jetzt aus, weil es zu wenig Leute benutzt.
Ich glaube, es haben einfach zu wenig Leute davon gewusst.
Ich würde es gerne jetzt nutzen.
Ja, aber so richtig skalieren tut es nicht, weil
wer benutzt noch so eine Bookmark-Toolbar?
Die ist damit halt irgendwie weg.
Ich meine, man könnte es vielleicht irgendwie wieder anders
in die Bookmark-Leiste integrieren.
Doch, jetzt wo du es sagst, habe ich aber schon mal gesehen, das Feature.
Wenn du dir ein frisches Firefox einrichtest,
hast du da, glaube ich, den Feed von der Tagesschau
drin oder sowas.
Genau, und das wollen sie so angeblich abschalten.
Das ist ein bisschen schade.
Aber vielleicht können wir ja noch
eine Petition starten.
Save RSS in Firefox.
Allgemein ist ja Firefox
dabei, sehr viel alten Code auszumisten.
Die stellen ja auch ihr
Interface langfristig
komplett von Zool auf HTML um.
Das sind sie noch ein Stückchen von weg,
aber das ist auch so NC.
Damit quasi die gesamten Codepfade,
die was anderes rendern können als HTML
komplett aus ihrer Rendering Engine rausschleifen können.
Sicherlich keine schlechte Idee.
Das ist ein bisschen zu optimieren.
Damit musst du zum Schluss nur noch eine Rendering Engine haben,
die wirklich nur HTML rendern kann.
Und damit baust du dir deinen gesamten Browser zusammen.
So wie Servo das ja auch macht.
Servo launcht eine HTML-Seite, die heißt Browser HTML.
Oder Vivaldi, der Browser, der in Electron M
ist eigentlich ein Chromium.
Genau.
Die UI in Vivaldi ist in React geschrieben.
Uh, okay.
Genau.
Ja, eine andere Geschichte ist, da habe ich einen Blogpost zugesehen, Firefox, das ist auch so ein bisschen ein heikles Thema, das können wir mal verlinken, ich habe da auch keine endgültige Meinung zu.
Firefox unterstützt ja schon seit einiger Zeit DNS over HTTPS, was eine sehr, sehr schlaue Sache ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Mal ganz kurz, kannst du mir mal DNS erklären?
Das ist mir unvorbereitet.
Also wenn ich jetzt www.akronymisier.bar in der Browserzeile angebe, woher soll der Browser wissen, welchen Server er jetzt anrufen soll?
Da muss er natürlich irgendwo nachschauen im Telefonbuch, was die Telefonnummer von diesem Mapserver ist, damit er den mit der richtigen IP ansprechen kann.
Genau, und da gibt es ein Domain Name System.
Das heißt DNS oder Domain Name Service.
Zumindest jeder Browser hat so eine Liste von DNS-Servern, die er fragt hier, ich habe diese Domain, was ist denn die wirkliche IP-Adresse dazu?
bevor er anfängt dann dorthin zu routen,
fragt er halt den DNS-Server,
wo ist denn die IP zu diesem Ding?
Und da hat dein Browser oder dein System
eine Liste von DNS-Servern voreingestellt,
du kannst das aber auch in deiner Fritzbox voreinstellen
und du kriegst das aber häufig von deinem ISP vorgegeben.
Da gab es mal so eine Geschichte,
bei der Telekom musstest du,
wenn du da eine Adresse eingegeben hast,
die es nicht gibt,
da hat dich der DNS von der Telekom
zu so einer telekom-internen Suchseite weitergeleitet.
und dann quasi deren Suchmaschine aufgemacht.
Praktisch.
Wo ich dann den Service angerufen habe und gesagt habe,
hakt's, wo schalte ich das ab?
Und dann musstest du dich wirklich in deinem Kundenprofil einloggen
auf t-online.de und musstest das dort ausmachen.
Immerhin kannst du es abschalten.
Genau.
Oder du sagst, andere kann ja DNS-Server.
Dieses System musst du natürlich bootstrappen, DNS.
Das heißt, wie kommuniziert man einen DNS-Server?
Da kannst du ja nicht den über eine Domain aufrufen.
der muss, ergo,
ist, wenn du einen DNS-Server betreibst,
reichen die Leute die IP-Adressen
von den Dingern rum. Deswegen ist es jetzt interessant,
eine möglichst coole IP-Adresse zu haben.
Google hat da vor Jahren
schon die IP-Adresse
8.8.8.80
irgendwie gesichert.
Genau, und rechtlos.
Und betreibt dort einen
DNS-Server. Und Cloudflare
betreibt seit kurzem einen auf
1.1.1.1.
Genau.
Sexy IP.
Genau. Und was allerdings an DNS problematisch ist, ist, dass DNS ein sehr altes Protokoll ist, was zum Beispiel keine Sicherheit vorgesehen hat. Ergo, erstens kann dir dein ISP übers Netzwerk vorgeben, welche DNS-Server du zu verwenden hast. Zweitens ist das Protokoll nicht verschlüsselt. Und drittens sagst du quasi bei jeder Webseite, die du aufrufst, deinem DNS-Server, welche Webseite du jetzt aufrufst.
Da steht jetzt nicht drin, welche Unterseite
und welchen Query du aufrufst.
Also wenn ich jetzt
akronymisierbar slash
Episode 20 eintippe.
Akronymisier.bar slash 020.
Genau, dann sieht der DNS-Server nur akronymisier.bar
und das Slash 020
wird dann im HTTP-Header,
wenn du dann HTTPS mit unserer Seite
sprichst, dann wähle ich HTTPS.
Natürlich, haben wir doch seit zwei Folgen jetzt
voll announced und so.
Ach ja, genau.
Dann sieht natürlich nur die Unterseite,
sieht nur der Web-Server, den du auch tatsächlich
zum Schluss aufrufst. Aber was der
DNS-Server, wenn er dann böse
sein sollte, machen kann,
ist, dass er dir
zum einen lockt, was du alles für Domains aufrufst
und dass er dir eventuell,
wenn du es nicht unter Kontrolle hast, wenn du zum Beispiel in einem
öffentlichen WLAN bist
und nicht in deinem System hart eingestellt
hast, dass du einen bestimmten
DNS-Server nehmen möchtest, dann kannst du halt
von irgendeinem bösen Router, mit dem du dich gerade
verbunden hast, einen vorgegeben bekommen, der dir dann zum Beispiel
eine gefakte Bankseite gibt und
deine Credentials fischt oder sowas.
Dem kann man vorbeugen, indem man
DNS über HTTPS macht.
Man spricht dann immer noch mit IP-Adressen.
Aber man spricht nicht mehr
das DNS-Protokoll, sondern man spricht
so ein REST-artiges Protokoll
über HTTP wahrscheinlich.
Das unterstützt, wie gesagt, Firefox schon seit einiger Zeit.
Was sie jetzt in der nächsten Version auch noch
unterstützen wollen, ist TRR.
Das wollen sie demnächst anmachen.
Das kann man auch momentan schon. Das ist momentan
Default aus und ist quasi auch schon eingebaut,
aber TRR steht jetzt nicht für
Transportation
Research Record, auch nicht
für Total Rate of Return
oder Total
Radioactive Residue.
Das passt.
Es steht für Trusted
Recursive Resolver, was im Prinzip einfach heißt,
dass Firefox
die Einstellung von deinem System,
welchen DNS-Host es nehmen soll
oder vielleicht der,
welchen DNS-Host dir dein Provider
sagt, dass du nehmen sollst, einfach ignoriert
und direkt den von Cloudflare oder Google nimmt.
Was? Ein Default of Cloudflare Services?
Genau.
Und das ist natürlich super sicher,
wenn du irgendwo bist, wo du dem DNS
nicht vertrauen kannst, weil sich dann
Firefox das nicht vorgaukeln lässt.
Aber ich will doch nicht immer alles zu Cloudflare.
So, genau.
Das ist auch so die Quintessenz von diesem Blogpost hier.
Das ist prinzipiell sicher,
solange man Cloudflare
vertraut und
voraussetzt, dass man der
amerikanischen Regierung, die potenziell jederzeit
mit einem Untersuchungsbeschluss
bei Cloudflare einreiten kann, vertraut.
Och, Mozilla.
Ja.
Also in diesem Blogpost, den wir jetzt in die Show
zu tun, ist auch beschrieben, wie man
das bei sich lokal ausmachen kann, wenn man das
nicht haben möchte. Ansonsten ist
DNS over HTTPS eine super Sache.
Auf jeden Fall. Sehr zu empfehlen an der Stelle
ist übrigens auch das aktuelle Chaos Radio.
Die gehen genau auf dieses Thema mit ein.
Das habe ich auf dem Weg hierher tatsächlich gehört.
Ja, dann sind wir immer
top aktuell mit dem Nacharm.
Ist aber, glaube ich, schon ein paar Tage alt gewesen.
Ich komme jetzt tatsächlich hinterher.
Genau.
Aber ich glaube, damit sind wir mit den schlechten Neuigkeiten
jetzt auch durch. Ja, passiert ja kaum was Schlechtes in der Welt.
Nice.
Du hast ja noch was über Go-Modules.
Ja, ich habe das auch immer dazugeschmissen,
weil ich das interessant fand, auch wenn das der Blog von Dave Chaney ist,
den ich nicht aktiv folge, aber das ist irgendwo
anders in meiner Filterwurzel gelandet.
Wahrscheinlich bei Hacker News. Ich fand es interessant,
Go ein Feature bekommt in seiner aktuellen
Meta, wo schon drin, namens Go
Modules, was quasi
funktionierendes
Dependency Management jetzt ist, ohne diesen
komischen Go-Path, den du sonst immer mitschleifen
musstest, wo alle Dependencies an
Version einfach auf einem Haufen liegen. Ich bin mir da gar
nicht so sicher. Ich habe irgendwie neulich einen
Vortrag von einem der Go-Entwickler gehört,
wo sie davon reden, ja, wir haben ja
Depp, dieses Dependency-Tool,
das sich so verhält wie
NPM oder
wie Cargo.
und wir machen das jetzt aber doch anders
als alle anderen, weil
so und so. Also von dem, was ich jetzt zumindest dazu
gelesen habe, heißt, macht Go-Modules einfach
quasi das, dass es halt
seine Dependencies in deinem Projektverzeichnis
vendert und nicht
in deinem globalen Go-Path und somit
die Dependencies pro Projekt einzeln gehandelt
werden und nicht komplett
geshared sind. Sprich, wenn du eine Dependency
updatest, womit Go ja historisch überhaupt nicht
zurechtkommt, das weil, wenn du
änderst ja die API nicht, Breaking Changes in der Library
heißt, neues Motto rausbringen.
Was der Tatsache geschuldet ist, dass Google sowas intern
nicht macht. Die haben ein großes Repository,
wo immer alles stimmt.
Super toll, auch für die ganze Welt.
Genau. Aber hatten sie dem gleichen Zug
nicht vorgeschlagen, dass man quasi, wenn man
eine neue Version von seinem Ding rausbringt, dass man
das quasi in den Unterordner packt und dass das jetzt
unterstützt, dass man Sachen aus dem Unterordner zieht?
Tolle Idee.
Das geht aber eigentlich doch schon,
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Nee, ich bin im Go-Equels-System nicht mehr so drin,
als hätte ich das sicher beantworten können.
Aber ich fand es interessant und ich finde es cool, dass sie den Go-Path
so mit obsolet machen, weil das ist so ein dummes
Go-Feature. Jetzt würde ich mir Go tatsächlich
gerne, wenn es so instable ist, nochmal
anschauen. Ne, beziehungsweise nicht
Go anschauen, sondern die Sprache Foe anschauen.
Foe ist ein
Transpiler von Foe zu Go.
Das ist eine Sprache und einen direkten
Transpiler dazu. Und das macht
nichts anderes, als einfach eine Generics-Ebene nur drauflegen.
Den Code generiert
und das dann ein Go weiterreicht.
Aber müsste man, wenn es Generics hat, nicht irgendwie
was mit G machen, sowie
Go. Ah, nee,
der Buchstabe davor.
Go?
Ich habe gerade,
ich lese gerade
And Another Thing, nachdem ich die ganzen
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
Nachfolger durch hatte,
die tatsächlich von
Douglas Adams sind, gab es quasi noch
eine inoffizielle
Fortsetzung von jemand anders. Von Owen Colfer.
And Another Thing.
Ist das der von einem Kaufmann?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich weiß.
Man merkt
eben auch, dass es so ein bisschen
so eine Fan-Fiction
ist, weil im Gegensatz
zu den anderen Douglas Adams
Geschichten extrem viele von den
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
Witzen referenziert werden.
Die haben sich ja normalerweise nicht referenziert
und da wird relativ viel angesprochen.
Von einem Kaufmann, genau.
Also es ist ziemlich gut, aber
so wie man bei Star Trek,
Quatsch, bei dem neuen Star Wars irgendwie kritisiert,
dass sie ständig irgendwelche Anspielungen machen, nur damit du so
einen Giggle provozierst
bei den Leuten, ist halt hier
auffällig, Gegensatz zu den anderen
Folgen, dass sie wirklich Witze referenzieren.
Aber es ist ziemlich gut.
Zumindest ging es da um diesen einen Typen, der
durch irgendeinen Zufall vor
Millionen von Jahren mal unsterblich geworden ist
und es hasst.
Der beste Side-Character in der ganzen Serie.
Und der kommt dann in dem Buch wieder vor
und dessen Objective ist ja,
dass er irgendwie durchs gesamte Universum reist
und jeden Bewohner des Universums persönlich beleidigt.
Aber in alphabetischer Reihenfolge.
Wovon er dann irgendwann abgesehen hat,
weil die Leute plötzlich angefangen haben, ihn zu erwarten
und sich dann auf den Planeten in langen,
alphabetisch sortierten Reihen aufgestellt haben,
um sich von ihm der Reihe nach beleidigen zu lassen
und ihn teilweise noch kreativ zurückbeleidigt haben,
was er absolut nicht machen wollte,
weil er möchte die Leute bitte provozieren,
damit sie ihn bitte umbringen.
Also in dem Buch,
spoiler ich immer kurz,
hat er von seiner alphabetischen Reihenfolge
abgesehen und beleidigt
Leute in zufälliger Reihenfolge. Und da gibt es
irgendwie eine Sprache, in der du die Leute beleidigst, wo du sagst,
you,
was ist das, sag ich mal ein Schimpfwort mit G,
ich hab mir das gerade nicht ein,
you stupid
git.
Gigit ist ja eine Beleidigung.
Das ist ja eigentlich eine Beleidigung, genau.
Und da war es eine Sprache, wo du
das Schimpfwort war was mit G
und die Anzahl der
G-G-G-G-G, die du vorne dranhängst,
das war kein Stottern,
die verstärkt quasi diese Beleidigung.
Das heißt, je mehr Gs du davorhängst,
umso schlimmer ist die zu beleidigen.
Es gibt generell so viele coole Sidejokes.
Was war das?
Es gibt in jeder Sprache,
also das ist ein witziges Fact heute,
aber am Rande, dass Douglas Adams da reinwirft,
irgendwo in der Reihe dieser Bücher,
dass in jeder Sprache in der ganzen Galaxie
gibt es das Wort, die krasse Beleidigung
und das Begriff Belgien
nur in den Sprachen, die wir auf der Erde haben,
ist das irgendwie ein Ort statt einer Beleidigung.
Das ist total random.
Aber so, Frank, okay.
Stimmt.
Oh ja,
Dankes Erd, das ist ein klasse Autor.
Hier ist gerade von Terry Pratchett auch sehr empfehlt,
mal wieder so ein paar Disco-Sachen.
Ich brauche mal eine Liste von Buchempfehlungen.
Ich wollte jetzt nämlich meinen
Audible-Account kündigen,
nachdem ich schon meinen Amazon Music Unlimited Account
zugunsten von Spotify gekündigt habe.
Allerdings haben sich bei mir bei Audible
mittlerweile elf oder zwölf Guthaben angestaut.
Das heißt, ich kriege noch elf oder zwölf Hörbücher
und diese Guthaben würden verfallen,
wenn ich mein Konto, wenn ich meinen Account aufhebe
oder meine Subscription aufhebe.
Den Account kann ich, glaube ich, behalten,
aber zumindest die Bücher kann ich dann nicht mehr holen.
Deswegen brauche ich jetzt unbedingt gute Buchempfehlungen,
damit ich mir mein Telefon noch mit zwölf
Hörbüchern voll machen kann,
bevor ich meine Subscription kündige.
Achso, Terry Pratchett.
Die ganzen Discord-Sachen.
Einfach der Reihe nach. Das gibt es 30, 40, 50 Stück
von. Ach du Scheiße. Gut, okay.
Dann bleibe ich vielleicht doch bei Autobahn.
Nice.
Wo wir gerade bei Übersetzung waren.
Dich hatte jemand angeschrieben für auf dein
Wikitranslate
akkronisierbar berichtete.
Achso, der hat auch Wikitranslate
angesprochen.
Du gibst
einen Begriff ein,
guck das per
API bei deinem lokalen Wikipedia
nach oder bei der Wikipedia der einen Sprache,
die du angibst, frag da die
anderen Webseiten an, zu denen es
in anderen Sprachen diesen Artikel gibt und dann
gibt es dir Übersetzungen auf Wikipedia.
Das hattest du in Swift
geschrieben. Jemand hat dich angeschrieben,
könnte das nicht Cross-Platform sein?
Dann hast du coolerweise auf meinen
Fork verwiesen. Ich habe meinen Fork
nochmal ausprobiert. Ich glaube, der geht nicht mehr.
Und es gibt aber jetzt ein cooles Projekt,
was ich gesehen habe, Tizen.
Das ist ein N-Curses-basiertes
Wikipedia-Konsolen-Interface.
Fancy Shit.
Das macht keine Übersetzung, aber es benutzt
die Wikipedia-API daher,
der
das ist tatsächlich irgendein
chinesisches Wort hier, Tizen.
Das sieht ja auch super sexy aus.
Also zumindest auf einem weißen Terminal.
Das ist halt ein
N-Curses-Interface.
Geil. Das ist mein erster Star.
Super cool. Gefällt mir sehr.
Wollen wir mal den GitHub-Stars
der Woche werden? Ja, nice.
Um gleich zum nächsten
weiterzugehen. Ja, bitte.
Ich habe mir von dem Dom,
das Dom auf Twitter
slash GitHub slash überall wahrscheinlich
siehe HelloSwift.
Siehe HelloSwift. Der hat eine coole App
geschrieben. Das ist ein iMessage-Spiel.
3D Mill. Das ist Mühle
und das spielt sich über iMessage
und das finde ich super clever als iMessage-Spiel.
Ich bin nie wirklich in die iMessage-App-Szene
reingestiegen, weil ich die Apps da komisch finde.
Aber das ist eine komische
Plattform. Aber das eignet sich halt wirklich
perfekt dafür.
Wenn du bloß Koordinaten hin und her schickst quasi.
Aber du kannst halt, ich meine,
es eignet sich perfekt dafür als Plattform, dass du halt mit jemandem
spielst, indem du halt den Spielstate
von einer Person zur anderen schickst und wieder zurück,
zurück, zurück.
Für solche Sachen gibt es, glaube ich, einen XEP für
Jabber. Natürlich gibt es das.
für alles ein fucking XRP.
Es gibt in PSY tatsächlich ein Plugin,
wo du Schach über Jabber mit jemandem spielen kannst
und wo du dann über Jabber-Nachrichten
der Spielstand ausstattest.
Warum nicht?
Ich meine, so was lässt du grad für so zwei Spieler-Spiele
super. Aber er hat dir natürlich wirklich eine App
gebaut, die
iMessage-Integration macht und
Nee, also du baust gefühlt andersrum.
Du baust eine App in iMessage rein
und die läuft dann auch nur
in der Message-App. Das ist quasi
eine Art Extension.
Und läuft genau in iMessage und du hast da die
Kometta-UI auch in iMessage und der hat
da so ein Scene-Kit, 3D-Welt,
wo du dann dieses Spiel spielen kannst
in iMessage und wenn jemand dir das
zurückschickt, dann kannst du auch direkt auf das
Geschickte tippen. Ich kann es ja auch gleich mal live zeigen,
beziehungsweise gehe ich auch mal auf die URL.
Dom, pack doch mal bitte in deine GitHub-Readme
Screenshots. Es gibt in Readme müssen
Screenshots sein, genau.
Ah ja, jetzt im App Store sehe ich es.
Sie sehen ein bisschen aus wie die Türme von Hanoi, bloß 4x4.
Die Türme von... Ach, von Hanoi,
genau, ja, genau.
Ist das Mühle?
Das ist doch nicht Mühle. Ich hab's erstmal wie
4Gewinnt gespielt. So, hä, wie geht's? Geht weiter, was?
Aber ja,
spiel's halt immer weiter. Das spielt sich wie 4Gewinnt,
ohne dass halt bei einem Schluss ist. Aber das ist doch nicht...
Achso, Mühle ist was anderes.
Ich hab's auch vorher noch nie gespielt.
Mühle ist ein komplett anderes Spiel. For all that I know, ist das Mühle.
Okay, es ist Mühle.
Aber nee,
spielt sich cool und passt halt wunderbar
in das Einmeldes-Konzept rein. Finde ich sehr cool.
Und gut auch fürs Open-Sourcen. Finde ich sehr toll.
Danke, Dom. Sehr schön.
Ja, schönen großen Entwurf.
Sehr schön.
Genau.
Wo wir gerade bei Text waren,
gerade eben hatten wir ja, wir nehmen eine
hübsche Webseite und machen ein Kommandozeilentool
draus. Das andere, was ich jetzt gesehen habe,
ist
Archive Vanity.
Ja, super tolles Tool.
Okay, was ist Archive Vanity? Archive ist
ein Hoster
für wissenschaftliche Publikationen
und zwar ein freier.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht bei IEEE oder irgendwo, wo du nur, oder wie heißt das, wo sie bei Methodisch und Korrekt immer drauf eintraschen?
Vergessen.
Also das ist ein Hoster ohne Paywall und allerdings auch ohne Review-Prozess, aber sehr viele so wissenschaftliche Publikationen, die so am Rande entstehen, landen halt auch direkt dort.
Und das Problem ist, dass diese Sachen dann häufig halt dort trotzdem genauso wie überall sonst als PDF in einem komischen Format veröffentlicht werden. Das ist allgemein so ein Problem von wissenschaftlichen Papern.
und ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal drüber geredet hatte im Podcast,
aber im Zuge meiner Beleg- und Diplomarbeit
habe ich mich ja mit wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten
und mit dem Arbeiten mit wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten
und User Experience auseinandergesetzt.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel an dieser großen Displaywand
eine Anwendung gebaut zum Explorieren von Papern.
Das heißt, du hast hier ein Paper draufgeschmissen.
Der hat das bei, ich habe das nur für einen dieser Anbieter,
für IEEE gebaut.
Der hat die IEEE-Seite per API und per Scraping angeguckt
und geschaut, du hast diese
Autoren, die da drin referenziert
haben, die haben auch diese Paper geschrieben
beziehungsweise dieses Paper
referenziert diese Paper und wird in diesen
Papern referenziert und dann konnte man so einen
explorativen Stammbaum von so einem Paper
irgendwie bauen. Und in dem Fall
ist mir eigentlich aufgefallen, man bräuchte eigentlich ein standardisiertes
Format für wissenschaftliche Publikationen, weil da hast du
Metainformationen, die immer noch mit rein müssen,
die du zwar irgendwie auf den Webseiten darstellen
kannst, aber die eigentlich mit in das Dokument gehören.
Gerade wenn du kollaborieren möchtest,
Zum Beispiel möchtest du für wissenschaftliche Paper eigentlich so eine Art GitHub haben,
wo du sagen kannst, hier, ich habe es da veröffentlicht.
Und ach, übrigens, in zwei Wochen sind diese wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse aus meiner Studie
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz aktuell oder jemand möchte was hinzufügen oder korrigieren.
Dafür gibt es dann so eine Art, wie gesagt, GitHub oder GitLab für Paper.
Gibt es halt leider nicht.
Du meinst sowas wie Sci-Hub?
Wenn der Name schon kommt.
Nee, aber ich will gleich da ansprechen.
Aber Sci-Hub ist was ganz anderes.
Aber wir waren bei Archive, geschrieben A-R-X-I-V.
Archive
und Archive Vanity nimmt jetzt PDFs
von Archive und
macht da hübsche HTML-Seiten
draus, responsive
HTML-Seiten, die man sich auf einem
Tablet oder auf einem Telefon
gut durchlesen kann.
Bookmarked war das einfach, oder?
Was du da draufschmeißt und dann
oder die URL tauscht einfach
Ausschrift und Vanity oben mit rein.
Genau.
Ziemlich schicke Sache. Also kommt auch ein
sehr schön angenehm lesbares Ding
hinterher raus.
Was ich festgestellt habe,
als ich gerade PDFs gelesen hatte,
ich hatte dann diesen komischen
Python-basierten
UI-Kit,
UI-SDK, was da an dieser Displaywand
bei uns in der Uni verwendet wurde,
gab es halt keine PDF-Integration.
Habe ich also PDF-Integration
mit reingebaut, so mit direkt
LibPoplar verwenden und das da
über einen Cairo
Buffer da reinrendern
und so. Wollte ich Textmarkierbar machen
und dann kriegst du Informationen aus der PDF raus,
wo in deiner gerenderten Grafik,
weil im Endeffekt ist es ein Bitmap,
wo dort Characters sind.
Und du kriegst dann eine Liste von Characters.
Wenn du mal siehst, dass du eine zweispaltige PDF hast
und du markierst Text,
dann machen die das genauso,
wie ich das dort auch implementieren musste.
Die sehen, okay, ich habe diese Liste von Characters an Koordinaten
und wenn der dorthin klickt,
dann müsste es wohl diese Koordinate sein.
Dann gehe ich der Reihe nach durch diese Liste durch
da überall ein Kästchen drüber, damit es so aussieht,
als ob du Text markieren kannst.
Was mir bei ein, zwei Sachen...
Das ist ein komisches Format.
Was bei zweispaltigen Sachen manchmal passiert,
wenn sie sie eingescannt haben, dass der Scanner nicht erkannt hat,
dass es zwei Spalten sind und dann markierst du eine Zeile
und es ist quasi eine Zeile aus der einen
und eine Zeile aus der anderen Spalte.
Das passiert, wenn du zwei T-Max-Paints
nebeneinander hast und versuchst du Text zu markieren.
Das kann auch passieren.
Was ich aber auch einmal gesehen habe, ist, dass
ein Dokument hatte überhaupt keine Leerzeichen.
Das war einfach breiteres
Kerning zwischen den Wörtern.
Ja, egal.
Also PDF ist kacke.
Dementsprechend finde ich es spannend
bei Archive Vanity,
dass wir quasi wahrscheinlich
damit auch umgehen.
Und ist der wirklich den PDF-Source
oder ist der den anderen Source,
der bei vielen dabei ist?
Ah, da steht doch was.
Genau, der download den Latex-Source.
Ah, und der will den Latex-Source
in HTML.
Dann zieht das nicht direkt
aus der PDF raus.
Ah ja.
Also PDF ist ziemlich scheiße,
aber hier nehmen sie offenbar
den Latex-Source.
Den hast du aber leider
nicht überall dabei.
Aber bei denen,
das geht, klappt das wunderbar.
Wenn wir schon beim Thema sind, ich hatte
erst heute früh, glaube ich, auf
Hacker News getrendet,
einen Blogpost von Torrentfreak,
wo es um Sci-Hub geht,
finde ich immer noch ein sehr unterstützenswertes, tolles Projekt.
Research gehört
free, nicht hinter irgendwelche Paywalls.
Und natürlich ist es kacke für die
Leute, die es veröffentlichen, weil
da gibt es einfach kein Incentive, das zu
veröffentlichen, wo es niemand peer-reviewt.
Oder keine Journalist, da hast du nichts von.
Aber das Geld, was bei einer Paywall dafür zahlt,
Das kriegen halt nicht die Autoren.
Nee, das ist einfach Schrott.
Deswegen Sci-Hub unterstützen.
Aber ja,
den Blogpost habe ich auch mit in die Schauner.
Druck gute H&N Kommentare dazu.
Nächster GitHub-Star.
Und zwar habe ich mir ein Tool rausgesucht, das heißt
Journal.
Also tatsächlich heißt es Journal.
Bloß halt ohne Vokale.
Nur die Konsonanten J-R-N-L.
Das ist ein CLI-basiertes Text-Journal.
Also quasi wie ein Tagebuch.
Und das mache ich jetzt auch schon die letzten sieben Jahre
Benutze das Ding?
Ne, benutze ich nicht das Ding, aber das nutze ich jetzt
sehr kurz und testweise. Ich finde es schön, dass es
sehr plaintextbasiert ist. Ich finde es schön, dass es die Integration hat
für die Software, die ich seit acht Jahren nutze.
Sowas hattest du dir das letzte Mal schon mal gewünscht?
Ja, ich bin auch noch damit nicht hundertprozentig
zufrieden, aber das macht vieles richtig.
Nämlich Tags und Query
in meine Journal-Einträge rein.
Und finde ich sehr cool.
Finde ich schick.
Echt schick, das stimmt.
Dokumentation kann man sich mal anschauen, die ist nicht sonderlich lang.
Und wie schreibe ich jetzt hier was?
Entweder du startest es einfach, dann öffnet
dein Default Editor, Wim, und
schreibst da was rein, oder du schreibst dir das
Command Line und schiebst in den Standard
Info-Ding rein.
Genau.
Ich meine bloß hier,
es scheint das irgendwie eine bestimmte DSL zu haben,
mit Journal Yesterday 2 PM.
Genau, also die DSL
in Anführungsstrichen ist
Command, wenn du möchtest,
Timestamp, den du auch mit Natural Language anschreiben kannst,
Doppelpunkt Content.
Genau, und die machen ein bisschen
die machen ein bisschen CLI-Standards kaputt,
im Sinne von, dass sie Flags ein bisschen anders
nutzen, aber
sie erklären das ganz gut und ich finde das auch an der Stelle recht sinnvoll.
Future-proof
und da haben sie einen TARDIS als Logo
daneben.
Your journals are stored in plain text
files that will still be readable
in 50 years.
Da hoffen wir mal, dass wir in 50 Jahren noch
ASCII-Textdateien haben oder
UTF-8-Textdateien.
Mal schauen mal, ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir in 50 Jahren haben.
Oder auf der anderen Seite, achso, ein
Blogpost, den ich neulich gesehen hatte, wo wir gerade
über 50 Jahre reden.
Fastcat,
das könnte ich mal noch
in die Liste tun.
Fastcat ist geschrieben von
Matthias Entler.
Witziger Side-Note zu
Matthias Entler. Matthias Entler ist halt einer
aus der Rust-Community Köln.
Hui, cool. Und beim letzten
Meetup hatten wir
mit dem Rust-Meetup Dresden
und dem Rust-Meetup Köln so eine Live-Schalte
gemacht, weil der ein Meetup zufällig am gleichen Tag
war. Da hatten wir über
Palawa TV so eine Web-RTC-Meeting
aufgemacht und dann haben wir so angefangen
zu reden. Es war ein bisschen schlechte Verbindung, wir haben die nicht wirklich
gegenseitig verstanden. Aber wir haben so angefangen, ja, wir wollten
mal darüber reden. Wir haben diesen Blogpost gefunden,
dieses und jenes, wie schreibt man gutes
Rust, so idiomatisches Rust von
einem Matthias Endler
und dann auf der anderen Seite
plötzlich einer so, das bin ich.
Wie cool ist das denn?
Und der hat jetzt wieder was Gutes geschrieben.
Fast Cat, äh, Faster Cat
Implementation Using Splice. Und da geht's im Endeffekt
darum, Cat ist ja ein Tool, was
dazu genutzt wird, um
Dateien zu konkatenieren.
Aber häufig wird's einfach dazu missbraucht, um was auf die
Kommandozeile zu printen. Was es aber einfach macht,
dass du so eine Datei aufgibst und der das
nach Standard-Auth einfach schiebt.
Und der hat jetzt überlegt, naja, ich hab
jetzt gehört von Splice, das ist
so ein System Call, der ist in Linux seit einiger Zeit
drin. Er wird aber von Cat selber
noch nicht verwendet. Was Plice macht,
ist, dass es irgendwie
File-Pointer kopiert,
ohne dabei
in den User-Space zu wechseln. Hatte ja noch
eine schöne Grafik reingemacht. Naja, bei einem normalen,
wenn ich was auf die Standard-Kommando-Zeile printe,
bei einem Cat, dann liest du die Datei im
Kernel-Space, dann geht die in den User-Space,
macht da ein Read, macht ein Write und
dann writet er wieder in den Kernel-Space
zurück, weil Kernel-Space ist Standard-Out.
Mit Slice kannst du
den User-Space-Teil
komplett überspringen.
Vorausgesetzt, dass du an der Datei wirklich nichts veränderst oder so einfach bloß einfach weiterreißt.
Und dann hat er erstmal überlegt, naja, ich hab hier, also was macht denn Cat?
Was macht die Datei auf und pipe die Zeile für Zeile irgendwo anders an?
Das schreiben wir mal an Ruby.
Und dann hat er irgendwie so eine naive Ruby-Implementierung hingeschrieben.
Und dann hat er mit anderes cooles Tool, was man mal empfehlen kann, ist PipeViewer.
Du kannst, der cuttet jetzt diese Datei
mit einem normalen Cut nach
Piped, die nach
PipeViewer und das schreibt er
dann weiter nach DevNull.
Und PipeViewer ist jetzt ein Tool, was einfach
die Übertragungsrate
davon misst und unten drunter printet. Dann steht dann da
bei seinem RubyCat,
das ist so 196
MIPS sind jetzt
Megabyte
pro Sekunde.
Ja, Mensch,
200 Megabyte pro Sekunde ist
ist gar nicht mehr so verkehrt. Was macht denn das normale
Cat? Oh, 1,9
Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Dann schauen wir noch mal rein. Achso, ich habe
hier das und das in meinem Ruby-Code falsch gemacht.
Probieren wir
noch mal
ein bisschen schneller. Probieren wir noch mal
einen Ruby aus. Zweiter Versuch mit
seinem Ruby-Cat. 1,9 Gigabyte
pro Sekunde. Und da hat er dann geschrieben,
wow, I didn't really try
hard and we're already approaching the speed of a
tool that gets optimized since 1971.
Stark, und das sind Ruby
In der Sprache, die ich gerade für gesteckt habe.
So, TLDR,
ich kann den Blogpost trotzdem empfehlen,
weil er ihn sehr schön geschrieben hat und natürlich, ich liebe Blogposts
mit Codebeispielen und mit dieser
wunderschönen Grafik, wo er hier zeigt, dass der,
wie der Code bei einem normalen Cut einmal vom
Kernelspace in den Userspace in den Kernelspace
zurückgeht und bei FastCat nicht.
So, und jetzt hat er natürlich Splice über die
Nix, über das Nix-Crate einfach aus der
C, LibC in Rust
angesprochen und im Endeffekt ist
die FastCat-Implementierung
passt hier auf diese Seite, das ist das,
das sind, schätze nochmal, 40 Zeilen Code.
Relativ einfach.
Er schiebt es quasi, importet
dieses C hier, Splice,
in einem Rust-Tool und schreibt es dann zurück.
Ich weiß, wie schnell es ist.
Und das sind 5,1 Gigabyte
pro Sekunde.
Stark.
Holy Guacamole.
Das ist aber drei times das fastest Systemcat.
Stark.
Das ist ziemlich schick.
Ich hab dann mal dumm auf Twitter gefragt, kann man das für sowas wie
Ripgrab verwenden? Da hab ich natürlich gesagt bekommen,
Das ist Quatsch, weil du kannst dann die Datei
nicht wirklich lesen,
weil du sie nicht selber in die Hand bekommst
an der Stelle. Du pipest ja quasi nur durch.
Aber es gibt noch ein paar andere
Tools, wo du das durchaus verwenden kannst.
Das Pleist gibt es nicht auf MacOS, schade.
Nee.
Genau.
Aber trotzdem super cool.
Fast Cat, das ist noch so ein
Blogpost-Star.
Nice.
Sag mal noch,
ich habe noch eins, das heißt Wallpaper.
komischer Name, Wallpaper mit Doppel-P hinten
und das Ganze ist eine
Swift-Cli, die
für macOS Mojave
benötigten dynamischen
Mojave
Wallpaper generiert, die dynamischen, die sie jetzt drin haben
und zwar kannst du da
genau eine Reihe von Bildern angeben
die du dann annotierst noch vorher
mit einer JSON-File daneben
wie für welche Zeiten, beziehungsweise für welche
Asimut-Werte oder sonst was
sie sind wohl dynamischen
Wallpaper so ein bisschen weitergedreht, als ich dachte.
Ich dachte, die hängen einfach nur am Timestamp.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es auf Deutsch heißt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es ausspricht.
Irgendwas aus der
Dings,
wie die Höhe von der
Sonne halt beschrieben wird.
Achso.
Und anscheinend
sind die dynamischen Wallpaper nicht nur daran
festgemacht, welche Zeit du gerade hast
und wann dann dadurch den Tag hinweg,
sondern auch darüber,
wie hoch die Sonne gerade steht, in welchem Winkel.
Das finde ich ziemlich interessant und
ich finde es auch cool, dass es da Tools gibt,
um deine eigenen dynamischen Wallpaper zu basteln.
Wenn ich eine Reihe von Bildern habe, dann kann man
das einfach mal machen. Hast du schon Fotos, die dazu in der
Lage wären? Nö. Ich habe gerade
überlegt, es gibt noch Leute, die ihre Kinder
die ersten 20 Jahre ihres Lebens lang
jeden Tag fotografiert haben. Solche Fotos
könnte man bestimmt gar als Wallpaper nehmen.
That's just weird.
Aber ja, könnte man. Oder zumindest Leute, die sich selber jeden Tag
fotografieren. Mache ich auch seit einer Weile.
Echt, ja?
Das kommt ganz bestimmt nicht jetzt Kaffee an.
Das könnte man als GIF machen.
Weil du gerade irgendwelche Geokoordinatengeschichten
oder Sonnenstandsgeschichten erzählst.
Es gibt ein neues Sigur Rós-Album seit Ende letzten Jahres,
das mir heute erst aufgefallen ist.
Und die haben ja immer supergeile Namen.
Mir ist jetzt gerade, weil ich eine Alexa in meinem Bad stehen habe,
aufgefallen, wenn ich mir von der Sigur Rós wünschen muss,
dann muss ich tatsächlich mittlerweile mal wissen,
wie man die Albennamen ausspricht.
Und das eine Album mit den Klammern,
das heißt ja wirklich Untitled,
Und die haben ja hinterher, die als Titel heißen Untitled 1 bis 15 oder so.
Und die haben dann später erst die Namen dazu ausgedacht,
nachdem das Album schon draußen war.
Vor allem nicht.
Viele Sachen sind Fantasiewörter,
obwohl man die von den eigentlichen anderen isländischen Begriffen,
die sie als Titel haben, nicht wirklich unterscheiden kann.
Das letzte Album, was sie wohl rausgebracht haben, heißt Root One.
Das hat acht Titel.
Und die Titel sind alles GPS-Koordinaten hier.
Das ist die Titelliste.
Der erste Titel ist
63 Grad,
32 Minuten,
43,7 Sekunden
Nord und
19, 34, 46,
3, West und so weiter.
Wir müssen jetzt, glaube ich, mal nachgucken.
Also wahrscheinlich gibt es wirklich eine Route,
wir müssen mal nachgucken, wo diese Route sind.
Du kannst einfach nach Google-Gabes Copy-Pasten, das kommt damit klar.
Das kommt damit klar?
Das solltest du jetzt der erste Sechs nicht mit.
Die liegigen Sechs musst du selber dazu tippen.
Das krieg ich ja noch.
So, das Album geht also los irgendwo hier.
Irgendeiner Höhle an einem See.
An irgendeinem See im Süden von Island natürlich.
Gut, okay.
Ich wette, das ist auch einfach die Straße einmal rum.
Das kann sein.
So, mach ich jetzt hier ein...
Kann man irgendwie ein Waypoint?
Kann man irgendwie Directions angeben und von hier nach...
Switch mal.
So, switch.
Und dann geben wir den zweiten
hier an. Und dann
Add Destination. Das ist einmal der
Weg, den Dirk schon ein paar Mal gefahren ist. Einfach einmal
die kompletten ausgehen. Cool. Also wenn ich
demnächst wirklich mal Urlaub in Island mache,
fahre ich da lang und muss dann wirklich zu diesen
Zeitpunkten dieses Lied hören.
Vielleicht ist es sogar so gut geteilt. Ne, so lange
sind die nicht.
Das wäre entweder ein sehr kurzer Weg oder ein sehr
langes Album. Ich wäre eigentlich überrascht.
Angeblich sehr cool.
Okay, das ist jetzt
Out of Order, oder?
Spannend.
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich einmal um Island drumherum.
Ja, es gibt ja diesen einen Weg,
einen Straßen, die einmal kreist
außen drumherum fährt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, die Adresse hat er gerade.
1.Island.
Auf 1.Island.
Ist das Reverse Geocoding so rum?
Oder ist es Geocoding? Ich kann mir nicht merken, welches es ist.
Island hat halt nur eine Straße und das ist Haus Nummer 1
Island.
Aber ganz im Ernst,
sprich das mal bitte aus hier.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie man die Zeichen
aussprechen soll.
Björn-Jvigur.
Das Einzige, was ich kann, ist
Ejafjallajökull.
Der Avokate.
Ejafjalljökull.
Das ist T-Jökull.
Haben wir jetzt eigentlich eine definitive Antwort bekommen,
wie man akronymisierbar auf Englisch ausspricht?
Nö, niemand hat uns geantwortet.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Sehr enttäuscht.
Ich würde ja sagen, akronymisierbar.
Wir sind ja auch akronymisierbar.
Ne, fang ich nicht mal damit an.
Ne, akronymiersebar.
Fuck it, nein.
Ich glaube, wir haben den Punkt erreicht.
Wir sind durch.
Gut, okay. Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns so lange
durchgehalten habt, uns zuzuhören.
Das war
Folge 021
von Akronymie...
Die nächste Folge
in eurem Bird Catcher beginnt in
3, 2, 1.